morning everyone it's
279 and then I'm going to recess 279
until we get a quorum and we get a
you
e
morning um we open the public hearing on
House Bill 279 I invite the prime
bill
thank you Mr chairman and good morning
good morning members of the committee
for the record my name is representative
Moren money I represent the town of
miramac in Hillsboro County District
number 12 I'm the prime sponsor and I'm
talking today in support of House Bill
279 an act increasing the penalty for on
premises lenses over serving alcohol
what re what we refer to as the
law House Bill
279 was introduced on behalf of the
croak family of miramac who are present
here
today tragically Elizabeth croak of
mamac lost her beautiful and full life
at the age of
20 to an over served and intoxicated
20121 by means of background House Bill
279 was retained last year by the house
Commerce and consumer protection
committee after several meetings
spanning a year the bill was recommended
ought to pass as amended with the
bipartisan unanimous vote of 19 to Z and
placed on the consent
calendar the Full House adopted this
bill as amended on the consent calendar
2024 the bill is amended does the
following and I'm going to be as concise
as I can in three
Parts my testimony has been emailed to
all of you as of last night attached to
it are two letters of support from the
governor and also a link to a WM story
that appeared last June featuring this
bill the bill does three
things part
one currently the maximum fine for a
lense e that over
serves is
$2500
$2,500 this bill would increase the
$7500
$7,500 for serving an individual who is
visibly
intoxicated or who are reasonable and
prudent person would know is
intoxicated and such intoxicated person
directly causes the serious bodily
injury or death of a person or
persons that's part one of what my bill
does increase the current maximum
fine part
two currently the license suspension
period is up to 10
days this bill would increase the
suspension period up to 30 days up to
days now on this point this is where the
house Commerce
Committee did a tremendous amount of
amending and so in the amended version
that you had that passed the house
unanimously and the Commerce Committee
following if a licen person in charge
managers security staff service and
clerks have completed the New Hampshire
Liquor Commission training within 24
months before the date of the
violation then the first offense cannot
exceed 15 days
suspension the second offense within
seven years of the first offense results
in a 15-day up to 30-day
suspension and a third off within 7
years of the second offense results in
license
revocation now I'm going to go off
script a bit and give you my thought on
that
Amendment and it was also the cause of
tremendous discussion in the house
Commerce
Committee in this
state training for bartenders servers
not the Liquor Commission offers
training and it's open and it's online
and you and I could take
it so the conversation that took place
in house commerce was well you know the
debate was well do we have mandatory
training don't we what do we do in this
and that so the idea was to incentivize
establishments to have have their
employees take the Liquor Commission
training there wouldn't be just an
automatic uh 30day of suspension and so
forth there's obviously a tier system to
that so the narrative here is that it
does not
mandate that training but it
incentivizes
it item three of what this bill
does the bill requires public
notification stating the reason for the
suspension I believe the croak family
will mention what happened in their
instance to The Establishment and how it
was not publicized their closing and in
their instance their establishment
closed over the holidays and it just
simply said happy holidays we wish our
employees and our
patrons a very merry
Christmas no mention of why they were
closing
down this bill if an establishment is
having their license suspended would
then be required to publish why in this
language liquor license suspended by the
New Hampshire Liquor Commission for over
serving of alcohol in accordance with
RSA 179 colon 5 a reason for why their
doors are shut for whatever amount of
time their license is suspended
which is determined by The Liquor
Commission Governor sonunu as I
mentioned earlier has submitted two
letters of support for this bill in the
house Commerce Committee I have emailed
those letters to each of you last night
and I've provided the clerk with hard
copies today also as I mentioned the
bill was featured on
WMUR the croak family this bill in
particular and what it does a link to
that news story was also emailed to each
of you last
night this is a very sensitive subject
I'm very sorry for those that um have
suffered because of over serving and uh
with that I'm going to close my remarks
and I want to thank you all for your
attention today and of course your
service thank you Mr
chair thank you representative um
speaking for myself I can say that was
one of the best presented bills we've
seen so far this year so thank you for
the time and effort you put into it um
couple questions for me
why not mandatory
training excellent question and that is
a long time debate now with me today is
representative kahill who is a
co-sponsor to this bill he has worked
for
years on mandatory training I he could
probably give you the best historical
and institutional knowledge analysis of
that uh because he's I would consider
him the resident expert on why it hasn't
happened thank you um also the the
suspension days um for over serving in
in my opinion seem a little light um
what was the reasoning behind that if
you could um was there a lot of push
back to making it stiffer did anyone
think about it and talk about it so just
to clarify a a number higher than 30
yeah well uh higher than 15 for certain
and and it seems to take a while before
revoked yes that uh 15 date just was
tied into the whole incentive to train
but I don't recall any specifics as to
um why the numbers were chosen that they
were okay thank you further questions
yeah um representative
jandrin thank you Mr chairman thank you
uh representative for taking my
question I noted on the bill that we
received in committee here um under the
fiscal
note that it says ex existing commission
rules provide for a fine of 2500 10day
suspension for the first offense $5,000
fine and suspension for 30 to 60 days
for the second offense but in the bill
as it was amended um I'm looking at line
12 that for a second offense it would be
a 15-day and a maximum of 30-day
um it doesn't seem it seems to me based
upon the fiscal note and what the bill
says is that we're actually Li
lightening the suspension for the second
that thank you I don't know if I have
the same physical not as you just to
clarify but I believe by what you said
um you may be right in that
interpretation because that's part of
the incentive to taking the training so
if you've taken the training uh then yes
it would be
quote unquote lighter than if you did
not have your employees take that
training follow up thank you Mr chairman
and thank you again for the allowing the
followup um it would seem to me that b
this line B there's no mention of the
training it's only mentioned in a that's
the lighter the lighter suspension for
uh the first offense has nothing in the
second offense even denoting that so
that's why I was wondering why it was
providing a lighter suspension and not
training I see that could be um a matter
of um reading you know maybe clarified
it could be more perhaps I'd be
interested in what the Liquor Commission
thinks of that very topic uh how easy it
is for them to interpret it since
they're the ones enforcing it uh based
on if they've taken the training or not
so uh I know the Liquor Commission is
represented here today and hopefully
they can pick up on that when they
testify thank you
um one quick question for me it it seems
to me that I understand the
incentivizing part but if someone's had
the training and they they overs serve
it seems they should be punished harsher
than someone who hasn't had the trainy
because they should know better would
you agree with that that that is a very
interesting interpretation and I had not
thought of that and that's not come up
but that is that's interesting I I would
have to think about that more because
that's the first I've heard that but
thank you thank you representative sik
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I'm hiding behind the
microphone from you um so my I I very
much support the concept of the bill my
question is I I remember from you know a
hundred years ago when I went to bars
that frequently friends would go to buy
around for the table for example and so
the person who was driving may never
actually be the person who went up to
the bar and be visibly drunk to the
people selling and providing the alcohol
and I'm just wondering how
like how that plays into this right
because in terms of the process and and
maybe you don't have the answer to that
but it just I think about when the
person is just at the table and their
friends are providing it from the bar to
them representative before you answer I
would just I would assum assume that the
Liquor Commission is going to testify
how their investigations are conducted
um because that would come down to an
investigation but if you have an answer
please B all means thank you very much
and thank you for that question and that
is a very good point and I'm glad you
said that because that came up pretty
frequently in Commerce people were very
fascinated by the process and wanted to
sort of uh mesh that into this but this
is solely about penalties not about
process and I'll say The Liquor
Commission I know they'll talk more
about it when they get to this table but
they have a process that seems uh locked
tight in fact in the case of the croak
family which they may mention they had
down to the ounce of what this
individual drank so in an instance like
that uh because the process seems to be
working effectively I think the Liquor
Commission would get to the bottom of it
very quick but this is a bill about
penalties with regards to an over served
intoxicated person who causes a bodily
harm or a death thank
you see no further questions thank you
for your hey
what go ahead represent Stone thank you
Mr chair and real quickly uh can you
explain why we haven't increased the uh
fine amount for the subsequent
offense I'm sorry why we haven't yeah
it's the same amount as the uh primary
or first offense I I would say that is a
decision made by the Commerce Committee
that wasn't in my original version uh
certainly something that could be
explanation good now thank you for your
testimony thank you very
much the chair calls representative
Michael
kahill good morning Mr chair members of
the committee uh my name is Michael kill
I represent Rockingham 10 the towns of
newfields and New Market and as uh
representative Mooney said I've been
working on this issue for a very long
time uh full disclosure I I drink
alcohol uh I may have a beer or a glass
of wine with dinner depending on what it
is and the weather uh I may have two
drinks if I'm at a wedding and
celebratory but not much beyond that and
I we've been working on this issue
because what what got my what got my
attention was a number of years ago a
restaurant in the community not far from
where I live uh was involved in over
serving it was clear-cut over serving of
three young men one of them underage
they looked at his uh ski pass and I
guess that was his ID but of course he
was underage and they served these kids
I'll say kids they were like I think
maybe 21 or 22 the oldest they served
these kids a couple of Dr drinks like
with multiple kinds of alcohol in them
and there was no doubt that there was
over serving uh not long after they left
the restaurant uh they went off the road
and I believe they hit a tree and the uh
attorney representing the restaurant you
know disclosed that yes there was empty
beer cans in the in the vehicle and so
how do we know who was responsible I
know those beer cans were from another
occasion where they're just driving
around and I know that kids drive around
with beer cans cuz I do I do a roadside
Cleanup in my town and I see it I see
the the beer cans the uh the little
little um nips that they sell at the
liquor store I I see all this and I pick
them up so I know people are driving
around drinking and that's not the fault
of the uh lenses but the lenses are
responsible for what they serve and
nowadays we can see on the tab how much
was served how much and over what period
of time so it's clear to me that over
serving is
happening so I I'm glad this bill is
happening I support the bill I don't
think it goes quite far enough I I did
try to have a mandate and the training
is uh about 30 minutes and I I passed it
without any study it's free which we
like in New Hampshire and yet the
industry was was resistant because they
didn't want to mandate and they said
well you know the people were not really
responsible because they PR game you
know because you know they'll have a
couple beer or two before they go to the
restaurant and I know that people are
bar hopping so you don't know how long
how much where they've been and what
they've had before they come into your
restaurant but you're supposed to take a
good look at them and see if they appear
to be and you know drunk and not serve
them additional
alcohol
um I had an experience uh at I think at
the prior election where I was out there
front of the polls and one of the people
standing next to me happened to be an
attorney specializing in DUI and you
know he represents his client and he he
he we T talked about this issue and he
said that you'll never you'll never put
an end to this long as long as there's a
greater incentive to serve and you know
it the uh the owner of the establishment
makes money the server makes money the
state makes money we're all making money
and unfortunately sometimes The
Undertakers make money so it it's a
complicated issue uh the industry is is
very resistant very powerful in this
state and they're not you know they
don't do all the serving the people just
have a house party they go drinking and
it's out of hand and we have this
culture uh of of excessive alcohol I
think we are we in one other state drink
like the most alcohol per
capita and uh I'll give another example
there's a restaurant I'm fond of um and
they never had any problems because
that's not the kind of place people go
to drink they have a nice meal they
might have a cocktail and a glass of
wine great uh the place was sold and I
went there with you know with the new
owner and uh I sat we sat at the barart
the place was packed and we happened to
know the
bartender and the owner comes out and we
compliment him on you know the recipes
are still good you know that's a good
marinara sauce you know and he says to
the bartender this this group in the
back they want shots and the bartender
says we don't have shot glasses because
we don't do that well use these other
glasses so we're going to have people
doing shots and of course that's peer
pressure you know let's do another round
and before you know it you shouldn't be
driving so I'm concerned about this I'm
glad we're taking some steps toward
addressing it uh I wish we would do more
and you know I also want to say that you
you see in the bill that all these
penalties it's up to so we know that
that can be less than the maximum again
I I wish it was more automatic but
that's going to be a very hard thing to
get through the Commerce Committee and
and you know it has to go through both
bodies and the industry as I said
well-meaning people but they're
protecting their
interests and had we done something
sooner uh other lives may have been
saved I know there was a tragedy in
Conway where a person was obviously
drunk drove into the library not to take
out book but he crashed and he killed
his passenger and that was before the
unfortunate loss of the croak family and
before the uh fellow driving around the
uh Circle in Portsmith didn't make it
all around he he flipped over a few
times and the young lady
died it's a serious problem and I'm glad
we're doing something but I wish we go
further uh that concludes my
testimony thank you
representative see you no questions
croak
sir I I I appreciate your picture could
you perhaps pass it around so that all
the members could see it I have a good
does good morning my name is David croak
I'm from marac New Hampshire and
Elizabeth is my
daughter I'd like to introduce my wife
279 on April 15th 2021 my only daughter
Elizabeth was killed by a drunk driver
traveling Northbound on the southbound
side of the ever Turnpike she was the
youngest of four children her three
older brothers James Matthew and
Nathan my daughter Elizabeth loved life
she was a confident mature 20-year-old
woman with a large than life personality
that spread love and joy to everyone
around
her Elizabeth was a graduate of Bishop
gon High School graduating with high
honors with many Scholastic
accomplishments she was also involved in
numerous Club activities as well as
played on the BG girls varsity
basketball
team at the time of her death she was a
dean Deans lless student at University
of massachusett in Amherst studying
Kinesiology with an interest in the
medical
field
the following is the New Hampshire
Liquor Commission Bureau of enforcement
summary on Wednesday April 14th 2021
between the time of 6: and 6:30 p.m. a
local Windham restaurant welcom 6 to8
young
patrons they proceeded to order multiple
bottles of discounted wine bottles were
placed on the tables and it was reported
that the group were pouring their own
glasses of wine with no
supervision
based on his blood alcohol level at the
time of his death a toxicologist
estimated that he had likely had at
least one bottle of Joshua Cabernet at
the
restaurant at approximately 9:07
p.m. the group arrived at another
well-known Bar and Grill located in
Windham New Hampshire they're all
regulars at this
bar the defendant was known by The
Establishment as a regular the BART
tender that night had served him
before on this night the bartender
served the defendant three tall mixed
drinks the three mixed tall drinks
consisted of vodka and soda vodka with
Red Bull and Captain Morgan and Coke he
also consumed a shot of green tea vodka
all within a 90-minute
period the human body metabolizes on
average standard drink per hour or 1.5
ounces of distilled Spirits per
hour the bartender that even evening
mixed a total of 6 oun of 80 proof
liquor plus an ounce of liquor that made
up the green tea shot or a total of 7
period the bartender on duty knew she
had already served that driver the
driver's three tall mixed drinks in in
less than 90 minutes and yet she still
served him the green tea shot which
consisted of a half ounce of Jameson
snobs at
11:44 p.m. New Hampshire State Police
received a be on the lookout for a drunk
driver's vehicle and he was described as
a h hazardous operator traveling on i93
in hooks
it roughly 50 minutes later he would
pass through the bed for tolls and
proceed to turn his car around so he
ended up traveling north in the
southbound lane narrowly missing a
head-on collision with a woman before
hitting my daughter ith's headon before
daughter headon at an estimate 80 miles
16.6 my daughter died instantly her car
fire at 2:30 in the morning two New
doorstep and rang our doorbell while we
slept
at that moment our lives changed
forever we had lost our only daughter to
an avoidable situation because of
alcohol the toxicology report of the
defendant indicated blood alcohol
concentration of 224 or almost three
times
limit aggravating factors failure to
train employees in liquor education
classes failure to take advantage of
classes offered by New Hampshire Liquor
Commission
failure to monitor the amount of alcohol
served to a patron negligent service of
alcoholic beverages person RSA 5075
semicolon
4 serving the defendant four drinks in
less than 90
minutes the penalty was a $2,500
fine and a loss of license for 10
days the bars response on a Facebook
post was we will be on holiday November
22nd through December 1st reopening
December 2nd with regular business hours
our hardworking staff has been at it 7
days a week all summer long and is
looking forward to this time we hope you
understand see you upon reopening thank
you for your support happy holidays to
yours they showed no
remorse the bartender fled town and she
now lives in New York
they turned a family tragedy into a time
celebration my daughter Elizabeth's life
was
special my daughter's life mattered she
had her whole life ahead of her a bright
light who always thought of others gone
remain in closing I have forgiven the
person who took took my daughter's
life his parents too lost their only son
who will have to live with the fact that
their son took an innocent
life no it's not okay to drink and drive
it is everyone's responsibility to make
sure our roads are safe bars and
restaurants have a duty to make sure all
their employees receive ongoing training
in all aspects of serving
alcohol it is the responsibility of the
New Hampshire State Liquor Commission
that training programs provide necessary
information to educ Ed ate bartenders
and
servers if training is a part of this
bill it is imperative that information
provided to servers and bartenders is
thorough and relevant with checks and
balances in
place it is a privilege to hold a New
Hampshire liquor
license no Patron should be allowed to
leave an establishment when he is known
to have consumed that much alcohol that
fast or when he shows signs of
impairment please support hp2 House Bill
279 in memory of our daughter Elizabeth
thank
you thank you for your testimony I just
have one question are you are you
satisfied with the bill as it is with
regard to the suspensions and training
Etc that you've heard us ask about I
think right now it's a start I mean it's
better than what it is you know what is
at current
um my only concern would be the training
portion of it um in Elizabeth's case Cas
if they had training and this you know
still
happened it's almost like a free pass to
me I just think
that um we need to send a clear message
that this type of behavior is not
acceptable and that bars and restaurants
need to be be held accountable for their
actions I mean there's been other CA
there was a case in nashille recently
where a motorcycle was hit with a driver
and a passenger that was killed and it
was reported that the driver that truck
had multiple um who sered multiple
drinks so it's it's it's a problem that
has to be addressed thank you um and I
speak for the committee when I say we're
sorry for your loss thank you for
Summers
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is Mike
Summers I'm the president CEO of the New
Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association and uh we are here in
opposition to this bill
um I need to give some some reference
here and and I I can appreciate the
emotion of of the moment but the thing
that uh concerns us for the industry is
that you have to understand how the
restaurant industry works we are a cash
flow business and we are not opposed to
an increase in the penalty of to some
degree Our concern is that this is a
300% uh increase in the penalty from
from 10 days to to 30 days I also want
to point out that this this part of the
statute this is just administrative
penalty this doesn't really affect what
can be brought against the business and
the individual via civil and criminal
penalties which are significantly more
onerous than than this administr uh this
uh action could take but I think what I
what I want to try to convey to you is
the concern from the smallest businesses
that if they were to be handed a 30-day
suspension of license the business is
essentially out of business and so that
means loss of business the employees are
unemployed whole variety of things that
Cascade from there and you know I I also
want to make sure that we understand
that whilst we are talking about the
very worst cases in the industry these
are a rarity in the industry uh the
majority of our of businesses in this
industry they work very hard at making
sure that there is no over service that
people underage are not served um a lot
of time effort and resources goes into
those training programs so we just ask
you to appreciate the fact that you know
let's not
um vilify the an industry that certainly
this is a risky uh space to be in but we
just feel that a 300% increase in the
penalty is is a bit Draconian um and
over the
top the other thing that concerns us is
you know yes uh there are are horrible
instances where this over service has
happened but we also find ourselves in
an age where we do have pregaming people
come in they just pounded whatever in
the parking lot um you know they we
serve them one maybe two drinks and
they're then visibly intoxicated right
and then so things can spir out of
control very very quickly we've had
instances where folks are you know they
uh have a couple of drinks at a resta
restaurant the dinner whatever it might
be then they take a a medication as
they're leaving whatever it might be and
again kids are experimenting with all
kinds of crazy things right now and so
now it be puts us in a situation where
you know it can come back to be a
penalty on the business and the business
legitimately had tried to do the right
thing so I I I I I think we just asked
that we uh we take a look at um what is
a reasonable
um a reasonable adjustment and the last
thing response uh representative kill
had repes referenced that you know our
per capita uh per capita alcohol
consumption in the state of New
Hampshire is the highest in the country
that is a misleading number and I ask
you to recognize that uh I think believe
even the Liquor Commission will testify
that 50% of alcohol sales in the state
of New Hampshire are made to out ofate
residents who are taking it with them
that is a significant number and a sign
and it skews the numbers heavily to
looking like we drink an awful lot and
we really don't drink that much um so I
I think I think at that point I'll leave
it there and uh and I'd certainly be
happy to try to answer any
questions thank you for your testimony
um what is the industry's reason for
push back on mandating the training it's
free it's only 30 minutes um um I'm
interested to hear
that because as as an organization we
try to testify or to support uh policies
that uh give greater Flex greatest
flexibility to our our business members
and that require the the least number of
thresholds and Reporting requirements
that can get us in a gotcha where it's a
penalty of fee Etc because once you get
into a license to serve which is what
you're essentially talking about here
there is now an administrative function
on the be on behalf of uh liquor
enforcement to track all of this
information I guarantee there will be a
requirement that the business has to
track all of this and along with all the
other things that we have to have in an
employees file it's just one more thing
that essentially becomes a gotcha if you
forgot to put it in there or or
something along those lines
further questions representative n thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um I'm wondering if you have
any numbers based on the uh restaurants
that you represent um how many actually
do the training without it being
mandated I would actually defer to
liquor enforcement that's not data we
would be able to collect necessarily but
I I think that they do keep a re a
pretty good record of of that the one
one follow on comment to that is you
know in in the way this training
component was added by house Commerce
we're actually okay with that clearly it
looks like there should be some clean up
in the language but we like the
incentive program right I think that
makes sense that incentivizes people to
do the training I think from a business
insurance perspective that would
actually improve their insurance rating
with carriers Etc so we're actually
comfortable with that and we like that
commer added it to the to the Bill thank
you represent Murray thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
I'm actually a bartender downtown in
Manchester and I can say I have never
received any kind of training on you
know a serving liquor and didn't even
know that that training was available
for free on the New Hampshire Liquor
State commission website um I'm just
curious you know if you feel like the
penalties are too high would not the um
uh compromise be mandating this training
I think businesses already have to
maintain you know records on their
employees and you know all these
different aspects and I think adding one
more thing to the list makes sense when
the cost is so high frankly I don't know
that it ever became a discussion on this
bill specifically when this was in house
Commerce you know there were been prior
bills Etc so I think we're open to a
discussion I think where we get
concerned is what does it look like
right how was the language written what
are the requirements what are the
penalties attached and those kinds of
things and and I will also say we don't
represent every single restaurant or
hotel in the state of New Hampshire we
have about 1300 members but that's out
of I I think you know six or 7,000
lenses in the state of New Hampshire so
again I I speak specifically for our
membership who I like to think are the
best
operators see no further questions thank
much the chair calls um I I always buter
your name uh mark armag in from the
commission thank you Mr
chairman and honorable committee members
uh for the record my name is Mark
armaganian I am the chief of liquor
enforcement for the Liquor Commission um
and
Licensing um just uh as I'm sitting in
the back of the room um I think a lot of
you know from me being being here back
six seven years ago when I was a State
Trooper for 28 years and what we have
done in recent years to to fix some of
the efficiencies and effectiveness of
the Liquor Commission that was the
reason or of the division that was the
reason for me coming over um one of the
things that we have seen and I have
learned um is that uh the division is
there to to um educate and create a
foundation of
compliance and that is through our
education platform it really is
compliance the success of the division
is through the compliance of our
licenses the the points that every one
of you are bringing up are very valid
points I appreciate uh both
Representatives who I've worked with
diligently uh to make some changes in in
this statute uh um but as you have seen
as the questions you you have all
brought up are questions that we have
had uh as we've gone as this new
Administration has gone the last 6 and a
half years so as as we move forward we
we see uh HB 279 as a step
forward um yes uh as as Mr Summers has
just uh mentioned um first I will say
that we have a great relationship ship
with our industry Partners our success
is to regulate this
industry uh for its own safety and
Community safety that that is our our
mission that is our vision moving
forward every day of the week um we are
we are bound by statuto St statuto bound
bookmarkers and those
bookmarkers um as you have seen in this
case the $2,500 in 10 days
um it even though this establishment got
the the max that they could get under
the law it at times doesn't feel good to
some people and and representative uh
you brought up a knowing that you're uh
a bartender um I won't say that I didn't
just send a text wondering why that we
have not we have a bartender out there
that has not gotten the message that we
give free training both online and in
person we will actually come to your
establishment and train your whole
entire staff that's what we do uh to
include licensing so it it does have
this balance of customer service base
and regul reg regulating the industry to
a safe level so when when uh uh I
started just to give you a little
historic background when I started
working when I first actually came in
stepped in the door probably a month
working with representative kill
on mandatory training it was met with a
lot of uh push back for a lack of a
better term um we tried to move move
forward with that year almost yearly uh
if if not every term um to see if we can
make some Headway this is the closest we
have gotten to mandatory training um an
incentive program if you will um that
has um some
promise um it has intrigued us um and
that is what has created our support of
this it's a step forward we're looking
at it that way is it truly where we want
to be it's not truly where we want to be
but it does get us to a point where a
establishment will see how much um uh
how much benefit it is not only to
community safety and and absolving them
from a little bit of liability but also
um uh uh getting their servers trained
in a proper fashion there are other
training programs out there tips is one
that is is mentioned quite frequently
but it doesn't talk about New Hampshire
laws and the way we do business in the
603 that that that's important here we
do it different and we are used uh our
liquor enforcement division has been
used quite frequently as a Kalia
accredited law enforcement agency as a
model throughout the country for control
States and we believe that being a
control state is the safest way to
actually sell and and um uh deal with
the the problems that come along with
alcohol
service um so so we talk about uh D
David and myself uh have talked I
countless times on on Lizzy's uh
negative in
and it is sad uh you've seen a picture
of her she was actually team certified
um and leaving a licensed establishment
at the end of her shift um which makes
it even more sad um in talking to David
uh and and uh representative Mooney and
representative kahill again were all
under the impression that this is a
positive step
forward um and and we believe that we
can make a difference uh with this bill
passing um does it fall a little
short it falls a little short in my eyes
I'm a dad I have kids in this vulnerable
age group I I look at Liz Lizzy's was
only a year older than my oldest
daughter um it it cuts at the heart
we're all parents it it cuts at the
heart and we want to see good happen
here and we believe that this bill and
moving in the right direction um is or
direction thank you um with regard to
the the
training how long is it um so our train
two training actually there's 15
training platforms everywhere from
training ownership and man
management um training servers training
the
people um on fictitious IDs and and
identifying uh persons that um uh have
partake in alcoholic beverages that that
probably did a little too much
partaking um
Grocers um our own our own liquor um
Liquor Commission employees that that
sell on a daily basis so we and and and
teachers uh because we also regulate
tobacco also and talk about Vape
products um and what they're seeing in
the schools so um right now the the
training platform
for um elcoho would be MTS Management
training and lots training uh both are
online both are in person depending on
how you you wanted as an owner and that
training class could be anywhere from
time wi because it is a PowerPoint pres
presentation with a test at the end um
anywhere between uh 45 minutes in an
hour if you're
proficient half an hour I I'd say yes
you could do that um but uh at the end
of the day it hits it earmarks all the
um all the items that you in taking part
in service all the items that you would
uh be confronted with both negative and
positive um that you should be aware of
to keep the industry safe and the
community
safe does your organization go to
license holders establishments and offer
this training absolutely and has you had
anyone ever say no thank you we're not
interested but not at all not at all in
fact I would say it's it consumes US
during some of our major events uh when
the beach opens up so when we work work
that that venue and I say that venue the
whole the whole Sea Coast when we're
working that holiday to holiday so from
Memorial Day to Labor Day um we have
seasonal um establishments out there
seasonal lienes those
lienes uh we
actually uh for the last three years
have gone to Bernie's dead center on the
beach and they have offered us their
venue to to reel in every lensey that
wants to be trained to say this is what
we're seeing and and I will say our
success is to share what we are seeing
in other establishments on a nightly
basis not to share your business
structure um but to share what is what
is going wrong not by name but by
circumstance and and again having that
open Comm communication between us and
our lenses has been Paramount to Our
Success our new success
so you would say that the relationship
you have with your lenses is more of a
Cooperative partnership than a
enforcement agency out there trying to
catch people up and hurt their
businesses absolutely so so uh Mr
chairman we have just and it's I it's at
Jael car right now so we have Rewritten
every one of our rules all nine eight
series we're going to have to create a
nin series series uh in the last four
years um that needed to to be done it it
it is what it is it needed to be done um
as we rewrote stuff we recognized that
the point system that was attached with
violations was
dated um it didn't benefit anybody to
include ourselves as far as
accountability um but accountability is
the the time suspended accountability is
a current but the primary goal here is
the education platform and that's why
our prog Progressive accountability I
don't like calling it discipline our
Progressive accountability starts with
the education platform so if there is it
let's be honest about it there are good
people that make mistakes and and those
people uh my years my Now 37 years in
law enforcement but my 28 years on the
highways of this state if people don't
know why they're in violation of a speed
infraction if they're not told why the
pros and the the the cons outweigh the
pros and and and at that point it's the
reason why we're writing a summons all
they're going to do is do it again and
and that is the the foundation of what
we've moved forward with here is you
need to know why why were're if we have
taken action on you you need to know why
and not the legal ease of why you need
to know from a Layman's point of view
what why you've done it wrong and and
how we can help you to fix it and and
one of the things that I'm appreciating
is my phone calls during the weekend
from lenes and and lenses who have
tripped and they actually are are open
enough to tell you how they've tripped
and how they can fix it and and that's
before somebody gets hurt so we're being
proactive in that regard um uh being
reactive is is what I used to do when I
worked the roadways out here and and and
my time in major crime and and you know
I always said we speak on behalf of the
victims and and in this case we are
doing that as loud as we can given the
circumstances we're speaking on half of
Lizzy right
now thank you um looking at the bill I
see a lot of a lot of significant
improvements it looks like a lot of work
went into the bill um I would prefer to
see some type of mandatory um training
for all of anyone who serves liquor in
this state however I wouldn't want to
see the jeopardize the entire bill over
that but we're going to look into that
representative um new and then
representative Bo and represent thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um I I actually bartended in a
former life and was tip certified um as
I remember uh that was in the state of
Colorado but as I remember um it was a
full day training um on a Saturday and
it's like you described with uh Bernie I
believe you said um and a lot of
different restaurants brought people I'm
just what I'm really trying to to wrap
my head around um aside from it not
being mandated is how how you could fit
that information that I still carry with
me to this day even though I'm not a
bartender anymore um of a full day into
a half an hour yeah so thank you for
your question representative um we're
we're two different types of training so
tips is going to give you the liability
portion of it but it's going to train
you in how to do your job we don't train
you how to do your job how how you
whether it's service or or we we train
you and what the laws are of the state
and and how you could get in trouble by
what what are the thresholds for old
over service what are the thre what are
the outward signs of intoxication no
also know this that in the statute
different than a lot of statutes and
something I had to learn when I came
over there is an affirmative defense
built into prohibited sales and that's
outward signs of intoxication so if you
if the two of you as as servers aren't
seeing outward signs of
intoxication it is impossible for me to
take action against you and that is
verified through video which is not
mandated in any of these
establishments so and and there were
some video problems in in the case that
we were just talking about not to get
into case facts but there you can only
ver you can only follow the evidence and
the facts of the evidence that is given
to you at that time you can't
assume uh what could have happened or
what would would happen cuz we we
possibly could end up in in criminal
court with it um where we're dealing
with Beyond A Reasonable Doubt and not
the 51% in an administrative proceeding
so yes um you your training is longer um
uh in tips than in MTS or in teams um
but we are hitting on the very facts
that you're talking about here today can
I follow up really quickly quick
followup um I as I remember part of it
was really trying to ascertain if there
were if there were Clues uh part of it
was kind of the the interaction the the
training on the interaction of how you
would ascertain U beyond that whether or
not someone had had uh been too
intoxicated but I also just wanted to
follow up really quickly because it was
a question I had asked someone else and
they said you might have the answer do
you know how many of the lenses have
taken the training What proportion I
actually texted when that question came
up I texted it to my staff I can get you
that number okay uh they haven't texted
me back at this point um but that's a
fluid number that changes
hourly um I would say it's a substantial
number um we have 6,400 lenses in this
state not all of them are in our state
1300 of them are out of state as direct
shippers um we probably have around 30
that number moves too but about 32 to
3400 on premise where you you both would
work an on premise estab
establishment um the rest would be
combination which would be your local
grocery store sorry your local grocery
store or Convenience Stores um so so yes
I can get you that number I I will get
you that number thank you I appreciate
that y um that just raised a question
for me do any of the trainings you offer
are any of them mandatory for any of the
MTS which is the owners yes what about
grocers
uh uh is there not to your best of your
knowledge some type of mandatory
training with regard to health from the
uh FDA and things of that nature I don't
know the answer to that question Mr
chairman um uh I I would I would defer
to them okay thanks um representative
rhods thank you Mr chairman I my
question is kind of two-part um is it is
it not already is it not already um
required for
under for training for so you're not I'm
sorry is it not already a law for
establishments to be
trained for to not serve to minors I'm
sorry someone under age of 21 yeah there
is a law on that yes okay thank you and
then with that there was a question
asked earlier that you you didn't touch
upon um that I was hoping that you maybe
you would as far as the question about
you know rounds at a table so if
somebody you know goes over and buys a
picture of beer they take it back to
their table is there are they is the is
the bartender or an employee are they
expected to check the IDS of everybody
at that table even if they're not taking
the alcohol to that table so yes thank
you for the question it's a great one um
so everybody in that establishment
should be
ided um as they come through or paired
with a parent let's use the 999
Applebees of the world that are are
restaurants and and they're serving food
and and I know during hockey season I
would take my girls there for a quick
meal
um that now you have at least you have
parental oversight of of what's going on
so you know that that child nine times
out of 10 is not going to take a sip out
of their parent drink but as a server
you need to be aware of that um if a r
round I think is what you're speaking of
a round is purchased and brought to
another table um that is the
responsibility of the establishment to
make sure that all those people at that
table even though their server hasn't
made that final service that all those
people that are partaken in alcoholic
beverages are actually of the legal age
of
drinking does that answer your question
I hope it does okay it does the first of
my question was um RSA
5B um where it says the commission shall
retain the right to require the lensing
in such a circumstance to initiate
additional training of the staff or
individual employee and so we do and and
upon I will say this too to to Edge your
point upon a violation of let's say
compliance we run compliance nightly uh
with underage buyers
and upon violation of that training is
mandatory we mandate training as part of
our negotiated
resolution representative
s thank you and thank you for taking my
question um which is what I asked the
prime sponsor and it it goes along with
the concept of buying rounds or you know
round of shots or
whatever um so is is the establishment I
guess how does the
establishment check the
sobriety level I'm not sure the right
terminology forgive me I'm not an expert
in this area to of of the people they're
not directly serving right so they give
Joe the plumber you know 12 shots and he
delivers them to 11 other Joe the
plumbers and how does the restaurant or
establishment uh monitor that so thank
you for your question representative I'm
sorry about the speaker here um uh and
pardon my back um so what we're what
we're looking at is a rate of service
and we're also looking at uh over over
service so um we rely investigatively we
rely on
receipts uh POS systems thank God
they're electronic now um and video um
if
a uh establishment doesn't have that I'm
just talking in investigatively if it if
it doesn't have that we don't have it
now that's not to say that the criminal
case doesn't move forward if if the
um if the person responsible for Lizzy's
death was alive they would have been
charged with negligent homicide and we
work very closely with the state police
on helping them build that
case um of of alcohol consumption at the
same time is is there
a um a responsibility of the
establishment yes both administratively
and criminally so we look at it from our
administrative
Authority um in in looking at receipts
and looking at how the service has been
done the umbrella of ownership has the
total responsibility and all that they
have assumed this
responsibility at the same time if we
have seen and this has happened a rogue
bartender who maybe doesn't like
ownership and says well I'm going to get
them in trouble and starts floating
drinks down down range knowing what
they're doing um hopefully we can build
a case a criminal case against that
which we have um I I will I think I can
talk about it now because it's been
adjudicated happy crab down in
Salem um we arrested or we
assisted Salem Police Department in
arresting um that bartender we've we've
arrested other through our uh uh legal
Authority we we have personally arrested
several bartenders who have egregiously
gone down this road it isn't something
we like doing to be quite honest about
it because we the success of this
industry is
compliance and and if you can make I
always say this if you can make a
bazillion dollars in compliance you're
my poster child um I'll bring on the
radio show with me and we'll talk about
how your successes and how you should
share your successes with other
establishments throughout the C uh
throughout the state or the country but
Muse thank you Mr
chair what kind of of evidence do you
have that um that the training is
actually effective so how do you
measure whether or not you're having
impact and and are there things that you
can tell by your analysis that let you
know maybe a certain establishment might
have a problem or things of that nature
so thank you for your question
representative we have several
barometers in this in this Factor one of
them being our compliance
if we are finding that uh a majority of
our establishments are in compliance are
iding uh through we're very active out
in the industry on a nightly basis um
and and we see that the service is
appropriate um through our
audits um we I think the the the
positive assumption there is that's
positive data that are training is
working um at the same time um I I will
tell you that to to hear somebody that
is not in compliance or fails compliance
bothers me and and I've been on the
phone several times with ownerships uh
throughout the state to say Hey listen
I'm sure you just heard this you just
failed compliance what can we do to get
you let's put a training segment to that
together let's do this sooner than later
and get your whole staff in if you don't
mind paying the extra hour or so to to
get it done but um but yes um it it it
could that that is one of the barometers
that we use to to show us that our our
training is
working
follow and how do you assess whether or
not uh the training actually sticks with
the people who take it
well first of all initially we do it
through our aptitude testing um because
you don't get the
certification um unless you pass pass
the final exam um and and I can make
that available for each and every one of
you if you find that you want to go
online and look at it um but at the same
time um it's it's literally our in in
face cont taxs with uh industry on a
nightly basis just we we're we're
constantly asking questions we're
constantly fortifying the
relationships um in a very positive
manner uh to make sure that just
business is done right and those items
that we talk about quite frequently fic
fictitious IDs over service prohibited
sales um that that that is all adhered
to and and you know that they when we're
asking those questions that they're
answered in a positive F or a credible
fashion representative
Jamon thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question you mentioned
my district I represent CBR and Hampton
including Hampton Beach so the question
I'm going to ask you is the bill changes
what the current suspension maximum
suspensions could be for first second
and third offense well third offense is
still advocation um what we want to do
for you is to give you a bigger Hammer
cuz what what what we always say is hey
if they don't comply use a bigger Hammer
so we want to do that I think you may
have heard my earlier question relative
to the fiscal note saying that currently
on the second offense it's a fine of
$5,000 in suspension of 30 to 60 days is
that correct still it it is and and the
point you brought up representative
first of all well thank you for your
question um the the point you brought up
is something that we brought up it it is
a unintended consequence of that that
Gap uh I believe but again we were
looking at this as a step positive step
forward um are there things that I
personally believe need to be tightened
up some of the stuff that you've brought
up and other committee members have
brought up yes but like like Mr chairman
you brought up earlier um I I think this
is going in the right direction we might
we be back here next session or the
session after that yeah we might just to
but represent
Newman thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um if this lower
to pass how how would the however many
3,000 establishments that actually serve
drinks become aware of this what how did
they know that this happened thank thank
you for your question representative so
we have a couple of um uh conduits that
we use to get this done uh we started an
industry circular six and a half years
ago because I felt
communication was lacking between us and
establishments if you don't know what
you're doing wrong or you don't know
what has
changed you're going to do it and who am
I to write you a on it if you don't know
about it now there are others that could
be even in this room that say that
that's not a defense to anything uh but
I I feel we have an obligation so number
one as soon as depending on when that
law change or when that bill comes to
law um we will message that out to
Industry we do that quite frequently
through our industry circulars um we uh
it I'm I I know he'll take a shot at me
but Mike and I talk quite frequently
with restaurants and lodging but I also
talk to the wholesalers uh our
manufacturers throughout the state um
anytime that there is a law change we
make sure that we provide that to the
industry that they know about it we also
mentioning um let's use Laconia for an
example for bike week and and wake the
lake and some of those events that they
do we do what we call a informational
Blitz um I send a group of our um field
investigators up to the region with
informational packets to meet with every
leny in that region to go over old laws
that they might come in contact with um
and new ones that have changed and maybe
you're stuck in your old way of of
thinking and and um that has been
extremely successful down at the beach
um we do that with our seasonal
licensees um in our open venue um
establishments our our concert
establishments uh we do it quite often
with our um higher education venues uh
for start of school spring flings
graduation our high schools we do a lot
of training with our kid our our our
vulnerable age group um with our high
schools in this state on talking about
um what they should not be doing and
abstaining from and and I I will go one
further we also talk about um those
those vulnerable age kids that have
tripped and might have partaken in in
alcohol uh products or vape products not
of legal Age and what resources are out
there for them to to receive help um
it's a different way of
policing um and and I believe it's it's
our success with this group is to be
very open but we're an open file we're
transparent a just totally transparent
chair could you just comment one one the
penalties is a revocation of license and
I'm just curious about who the lenes are
are they the owners can some somebody
else own a license in a restaurant uses
that license or how does that work and
is that revocation final for the leny or
the establishment it can go thank you
for your question representative so it
can go either way depending on where the
evidence takes us um if we see a total
failure by
ownership um that that owns that LLC
through our lure process um and the
Secretary of State's office um then then
we will hold them liable but this can
drill all the way down to a server um
and not being responsible um have we
talked about ler we just did we talked
about L individual
ler um I would that be met with
resistance I it has uh been met with
resistance but it is another another
tool that could be used that other
states do um I don't think I I truly
believe that in the amount um this this
is a bad statement but we don't deal
with this issue often um sadly somebody
died from this issue and and that
somebody's name is Lizzie and and she
had her life that was a beautiful life
that was taken away from her um I can't
not plug myself into that circumstance
myself and my wife um knowing that I
have kids at that are her same age and
she did it right she was team certified
so um and actually in this folder I do
have two things a picture of the
crash um that was horrific and a picture
of uh or a copy of her certificate that
I will I have uh little momentos that uh
from from families that um I in this in
the several hundreds of homicide cases
over a 14-year career in major crime
that that the families have left me as
momentos to remember and and this will
be a momento to remember her as I do my
job on a daily basis to the day I walk
away from this job
thank you for your testimony today is
there anyone else who hasn't testified
that wishes to testify on this bill just
one one last thing j representative
Pratt just one quick one uh how you
doing uh I have a quick question here do
you still do spot inspections where send
people in to do uh buying that maybe
Miner send miners in to do inspections
absolutely and then also license renewal
inspections you still do license
absolutely yeah so those are pretty Thor
I know in my past and and that is an
opportunity for our investigators to go
out and actually speak about what has
changed very good point representative
thank you for that um so that when we do
those in uh those inspections it it is
all it is all around a conversation
about what has changed how business is
going and what we can do to help you be
more successful um but we always talk
about the elephant in the room and
that's the negative that Could Happen um
it's it has a lot of liability around it
as you know from from you know your
service your public service um there's a
lot of liability around that that uh
could go negative really quick thank you
thank you again thank you for your
testimony
ma'am if you have something new to add
absolutely you got to push the excuse
me am I live okay sorry um this is just
in response to something the
commissioner said which I want to
clarify and I think is often an area of
confusion in certainly civil cases
involving the liability of
establishments that serve alcohol but
apparently also confusion I think for
the commission I heard the commissioner
say there's an absolute defense an
affirmative defense for an entity to a
claim that they were um over serving if
the person was not visibly
intoxicated um we in litigating this
case uh came up against that issue
numerous times and although there are
affirmative defenses under the statute
which say if a business can show that
they've been involved in reasonable
business practices they may be able to
fend off liability the statute
specifically says that a entity is
responsible if they bartenders or
servers serve somebody who is visibly
intoxicated or whom a reasonable person
would know is intoxicated and in this
case you had in both entities servers
saying there were no visible signs of
intoxication and part of how we proved
that there was the the person was
intoxicated and they should have known
that was from how much they had been
served over what period of time and
there's actually a federal court opinion
from Judge llant that said is it's not
just visible signs of intoxication so I
say that just because I hate to have on
the record some um sense that if
somebody's not visibly intoxicated you
can keep serving them you know if
there's somebody who holds their liquor
uh sort of invisibly that you're free to
serve them as much as you want thank you
um speaking of on the record before you
leave could you fill out a pink card for
us so we have you and I'm not it's one
more question um the reason person
standard raises an interesting question
because what does a reasonable person
know about alcohol and how much and if
you have to take training your
reasonableness is the bar goes a little
bit higher because now it's a reasonable
trained person versus a reasonable
untrained person would you agree uh I
would say that's true um but because
training isn't
mandatory um we have a situation where
you know we're looking at some people
um for instance representative Murray
who is serving people and is untrained
so what standard are you going to apply
the reasonable person standard has to be
the lowest an untrained person however
if it were mandatory that would raise
that that bar wouldn't it right and in
this case although the owners are
required to take this MTS Management
training they then in in the case of one
of these bars did not turn around and do
any in-house training themselves
specific to over service or at least
that was the testimony from the servers
was that their management had never
passed on any training to them even
though they had received the training
thank you very much for your addition
today um with that I'm going to close
this public hearing and I would ask the
Republicans to meet me in my office
we're going to probably exec this bill
today if anyone's interested in staying
for
that
spe
thank you um with that I'm opening the
executive session on House Bill
279 and excuse me uh 279 and I am going
to recognize myself I make a motion of a
to pass have a second representative
Jamber in
seconds and real quick um I saw some
things in this bill that I would like to
see changed having said that this was a
Commerce bill first and I respect their
decision
um having said that I I do think some
things need to be toughened up including
the the mandatory training and I look
forward to see what happens in the
Senate having said that this has a still
a bit to travel so we're going to move
it along representative Jam would you
like to speak to a second yes Mr
chairman I I agree um the second offense
is lighter than what it currently is and
I and I think that it should be
toughened uh however uh the time can be
done that can be done in the Senate and
uh we can recommend that as members of
the house at that point Thank you
further
discussion seeing no further discussion
role motion on the floor is um ought to
pass the motion Was Made by Me seconded
Jamon Vice chair Bros yes representative
Pratt yes yes representative scitec
representative pu yes representative
jandrin yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenar yes
representative Harry Gite yes
representative Muse yes
representative Brad uh Murphy yes
representative
Newman the clerk cootes yes
representative Newell yes representative
selig yes representative wheeler yay
Vice chair rootes or sorry chairman Roy
chair rootes yes 180 180 ought to pass
passes um any objection consent seeing
none to go on consent calendar and with
that I close the executive session on
House Bill
279 and I open the executive session on
1137 oh excuse me I jumped the gun the
good morning um Mr chairman and members
of the committee um I'm representative
Linda massamilla I represent Grafton
District 1 I'm going to be brief as I'm
supposed to be meeting with a group of
students from St Olaf University right
now so I just wanted to respectfully ask
you to itl um House Bill
1137 after listening to and talking with
several stakeholder groups um about
their concerns that had to do the
vagueness of the language and the
changes in fees and restitution we
decided to ask that this be itl so we
can work on it sometime over the summer
and bring it back next Year and thank
you very much for your time and
consideration thank you for letting us
know your wishes and we always
appreciate it when someone comes forward
and lets us know what they like right
out of the gate good luck with the
students is there anyone else here who
would like to testify on House Bill
1137 seeing none I Clos the public
hearing at House Bill
1137 I open executive session House Bill
11:37
and excuse me no
11:37 yeah I'm executing the bill we
just so it's
11:37 what is going on around
here um make motion Mr chair I make a
motion of itl for House Bill
1137 seconded by representative um har
gather um would you like to speak to
your motion representative Ro
thank you Mr chairman um going to go
ahead with what the sponsor requested
and the reason she gave it look sounds
like we're going to or they're going to
do some more work on it and bring back
language that we would all be able to
pass so um let's do
it represent har G would you L to speak
to your motion same very good any
further discussion seeing nonetheless
cour call the role motion of floor is in
legislate Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt yes representative
saac yes representative pu yes
representative jandrin yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tzar yes representative
Harry cther yeah representative Muse yes
representative
Murphy represent representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
suig yes representative wheeler chairman
Roy chair votes yes
170 any more um objection to consent
seeing none it will go on consent and
expedient to legislate unanimous I
hereby close the executive session on
House Bill
1137 I open a public hearing on House
Bill 1177 and invite the prime sponsor
bill
good morning the prime sponsor uh R
Manos couldn't be here today so I am a
co-sponsor and introducing the bill I'm
wiam this bill seeks to
have petitions for domestic violence or
stalking filed
electronically the court has been trying
to move cases a little bit at of time
over a 10year process to be electronic
many of them are still in hard copy
format
and that makes it difficult to for for
for multiple judges to be able to look
at something you've got a hard copy of a
file and there are times
when somebody will have a criminal
protective order against person a will
have it against person B because
something happen and somebody was
arrested person B can then go into
family court and not tell them that
there's already a protective order
against them and person B can then get a
protective order against person
a the police have to go by which order
was issued latest now they're likely
going to ask for the person a is
obviously very likely going to ask for
an emergency hearing it'll be heard
within 5 days but in the meantime
they're likely going to be kicked out of
their house there quite a few examples
that we heard of this happening with
different family law attorneys and so
that was one of the reasons for putting
in this bill another reason for putting
in the bill was just simply to be able
to
have more statistical data on these
types of cases so these petitions to be
clear are petitions that usually happen
in Family Court they're not criminal um
cases um
and even though it's in your committee
which I guess confusing because you guys
usually deal with the criminal ones but
this is these are ones that would
wouldn't happen in in criminal
court so that was the reason for putting
this in there was a little bit of
concern in here related
to the fact that it had said shall be
electronically filed
and um the idea that it said that a
party could be excused under the
circumstances that it would create a
hardship
and there was a little bit of a concern
that somebody may be able to use that
for a reason of appeal in a true devv
situation and say well you know their
extraordinary circumstance was that they
didn't have a car and I don't think that
that's extraordinary and then try and
use it for a reason of appeal and so for
that reason we would be okay changing
this from Shell to May and then removing
the second sentence um but that's that's
what the bill does and I'm happy to take
any question
questions thank you um first of all if
we get if we get that far that an
amendment is appropriate in the
committee belief so then we're going to
ask you to get whatever amendments that
are necessary um representative Jamon
thank you Mr chairman uh currently uh
the police show up your at your doorstep
for a domestic call and they believe
there's an emergency situation and they
must have a protective order in place
within minutes um they then pick up the
phone I'm I'm I'm asking this is part of
a question they immediately call a judge
the judge issues an order over the phone
and then a paper copy of that order is
then forwarded to the police department
to be served on the second party um
would your bill neuter that and not
allow the telephonic order order or is
it is it in compliment to
that attorney krian can probably give
better data than but I don't believe
right now I think you would still have
to fill out unless it was criminal if it
was going to be this is again not for
criminal this is civil so somebody
hasn't committed a crime you're going to
have to fill out a petition and usually
the petitions are done during working
hours it's a very rare circumstance when
something would be granted outside of
hours and attorney crean might have the
data on exactly how often that happens
but it's very seldom that that would
happen but yes it is all hard C copy and
there's one copy in the court um and
that's you know kind of another thing
with with hard copy files if anything
ever happens to the court we don't have
a a copy of that there's no electronic
copy thank
you representative
n thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um my question is
what this says is anything petitions
filed on or after um July 1st 2025 and
so my question is if there's something
that's existing at that time would that
also be electronically filed or is it
just for things that are happening after
that so is it for petitions that um that
are filed on or after that time or
anything that is in existence at that
time would be electronically filed so
that it could be shared it would be from
petitions that are filed from that from
that period on so you know existing
cases or cases that didn't have
decisions yet those wouldn't be included
in here because this strictly talks to
petitions from from then forward okay
thank you thank you for the question
representative
scitec I'm a little confused it's you
say this the title is relative the
electronic filing of domestic violence
civil that's
just they're done in Family Court that's
what it that's just how it's done so
they're they're parties that are either
related to each other or they're done um
or they're in a relation ship with each
other there's certain criteria that
those that those fall
into but it's not a crime has not been
the person hasn't been arrested for
something prior to these
happening okay I expect a more in-depth
um explanation by attorney krian from
the court see you no further questions
thank you for your testimony the chair
Kylie
um good morning Mr chair and members of
the committee um as you know my name is
Pamela kyg and I'm the public policy
specialist at the New Hampshire
Coalition against Domestic and Sexual
Violence um I am here today also with my
colleague Joy um who is our program
director and um we just kind of wanted
to Echo what um representative kutab
said that we share similar concerns and
would recommend that the language in the
bill be changed from Sha to May and I do
have a suggested amendment of language
that I will pass around with my
testimony um and we're happy to answer
any questions that you have related to
the protective orders for both um
domestic violence under 173b and
stocking under 633 um 3A I think and
then um I think just the the Crux of Our
Testimony is that we just feel very
strongly that mandatory um electronic
filing um is not in the best interest of
victim safety are we feel very strongly
that we want to create more options so
that's why we're we are open and excited
for the possibility of having electronic
filing as an option but want to make
sure that inperson filing and um also a
remote process that we've been piloting
with the court since uh 20120 um remain
intact um just so that victims and
survivors have as many options a aable
to meet their safety needs as they're uh
seeking relief uh from the courts um I
think my colleague Joy will just quickly
highlight some of the key concerns that
we just wanted to make sure we're on
your radar um with a solely uh
electronic
process thank you um so as as Pamela had
mentioned we um implemented in 2020 um
as we were recognizing the significant
barriers that survivors were facing due
to
covid-19 um we formed a
multi-disciplinary committee that was um
looking at uh allowing temporary
electronic filing options um filing the
petitions uh during regular business
hours at the court uh the committee was
comprised of Court staff New Hampshire
legal assistants uh the Coalition and
private attorneys among other experts
and stakeholders this process was
intentionally created to balance the
safety needs of survivors and the
existing technology systems available
through the court
um through this process survivors work
directly with crisis centers to file
these remote email petitions and they
would also be directly connected to
Legal Services the remote filing is
still available today even though we no
longer have the concern of covid-19 um
and most crisis centers continue to use
this as an option when working with
survivors some of the concerns uh that
we have that was stated previously we we
oppose that this bill um is would be
mandatory it would be mandatory for
people to file petitions electronically
um and that there would be any type of
sort of red tape uh requirements to
demonstrate that victims are allowed to
file in person it's really important to
keep those options open because every
Survivor is the expert in their
situation and their safety and we want
to make things as accessible for them as
possible when seeking uh orders of
protection and um one specific concern
uh some of our specific concerns that we
have is that this legislation as written
would require uh demonstrating that
electric filing is a
hardship um and as written it would
actually discourage survivors from
coming forward um because again it's
another barrier that we're putting in
place and there's no consideration for
language needs and Technology barriers
so not everyone is it's not you know we
really need to take into consideration
making these things as accessible as
possible for anybody
um Tech safety concerns uh could also be
a serious issue for survivors because we
really want to think about what what
does that look like in the court if
people are electronically filing at a
kiosk so to speak in the middle of the
courthouse how is that safe uh what
happens if their perpetrator shows up at
the court um so again these are things
that we want to take into consideration
and obviously the impact on survivors
with disabilities uh Child Care issues
people may not be able to get to the
courts um in order to file due to not
having Child Care um time constraints
and privacy and then how again would
would survivors get connected to
resources such as crisis centers and
legal services if they're filing um
electronically on their own yeah um and
we'd be happy to expand on that if there
are any more specific questions but I
think in summary we just really
appreciate the work of the sponsors on
this and the level of collaboration that
we've had to um look into how this
process might work um and just uh really
strongly urge that the language be
changed to May so that the option is
available but it's not the sole option
um for victims and we'd be more than
happy to take any
questions thank you representative Stone
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question can you explain to me
in your opinion what an extraordinary
circumstances would
be I think that's a really great
question representative I'm not entirely
sure um what the the vision was behind
that language but I I would argue that
um someone fleeing abuse who may have
been strangled or any other thing is
already experiencing an extraordinary
hardship followup so in reference to the
actual filing of the of a petition uh I
guess I heard some of your testimonies
that it's kind of Envision an individual
could go to an organization that would
help them on their behalf fill out the
electronic filing or go go to a court
which obviously we are all aware that I
believe most courts in New Hampshire
staff of court security Personnel that
have powers of arrest as well so it
should be a safe environment uh I do
agree that the shell language is uh kind
of strong and may would be a better
venue in my opinion but the
extraordinary circumstances is the one I
had the real issue with I couldn't
Envision what you would Define as one
yeah I think I think there was really
good intent um with the idea I think uh
to make sure that there could be an
option if electronic filing wasn't
feasible but I just I think our concern
is that if someone's already going to
the court to file a petition we don't
want them to have to have that initial
step to demonstrate and that it could
actually be inadvertently used um by
abusers um to make it even harder so
thank
you to the best of your knowledge does
the bill allow electronic filing like
from home or does it have to be at a
centralized location it uh it's our
understanding the intention of of this
bill would uh would indicate that uh
individuals would have to go to the
court in order to electronically file
and not file from home I think I think
that's a really great question and I
think maybe the courts could lend some
um recommendations into what the
infrastructure would look like I think
uh right now there there was um in in
talking with the sponsors um there was
thought of you know do we have a kiosk
like um for some of the other petitions
that are filed is there a platform
online um and I think until those pie
are ironed out and we know what that
looks like I think it's hard to know if
there's any other considerations that
might need to be in
place I just I I worry that um online is
is very dangerous because oftentimes
abusers will look at internet history
and you could end up in a worse
situation you started with but that
perhaps isn't an issue today um further
questions for this witness
representative here at gather thank you
ch um my question is today
you can go into the courts correct but
did you also say that you still can do
online so we we'll clarify that yeah yes
so um today survivors have the option of
going to the court to file um themselves
or with any support person including a
crisis center Advocate um to help
support them through that process they
may also have a legal counsel or
representation that can help them
through that process with filing there
is also another option
um where survivors can work with crisis
centers to um to remotely file a
petition that goes directly to the court
um so they can do that in their offices
um it's a safe and comfortable
environment they can also bring their
children um and there would be the you
know just eliminates a lot of barriers
because they're already getting
connected to those crisis center
Services right away and they can file
that petition remotely there yeah and So
like um my colleague mentioned this was
something that was crafted in 2020 in
May 2020 during the Crux of covid um
when we knew that getting to the
courthouse was especially challenging
for survivors um and so uh while the you
know the initial sort of Nexus for why
we have this is no longer the same the
issue we have today um this process
Still Remains available um not a lot of
petitions are filed this way but we have
found that it's been very helpful
especially for survivors with dis
abilities who may not physically be able
to get to the court or in cases where
you know there are multiple children who
maybe the the person doesn't have a
caregiver and can then work with the
advocate at the crisis center to submit
it but there's a very strict criteria um
of how that um can be filed and it again
has to be um you know the the purpose
being that they would have the support
they need to file it remotely um it's
not anyone at home that can access this
process thank
you
see no further questions thank you also
I want to take the a moment that um
whenever we have a domestic violence
issue here I think it's important we
bring up the fact that there may be
people at home watching um you can
always text 911 you do not have to call
so if you feel like you're not safe at
your house you do not have to call 911
you can text it and help will arrive
thank you thank you chair
recognizes um attorney Aon krian from
courts hello Representatives just
appearing on behalf of the judicial
branch to discuss
1177 um and I want to start by saying
that we appreciate so much that we've
had a lot of Engagement with the uh
sponsors of this bill they've come over
to the court system we've walked them
through some of the filing options that
we have um and I hope we'll continue
having a conversation with them um just
sort of three principles I I want to
orient you to with the bill and the
first is that the courts are absolutely
supportive of having more efiling
options for for state courts throughout
the country uh it is a generally a
gradual transition from paper filing to
electronic filing some states have
completed it Most states in the New
England region have not um so it is a
process we have been working on for over
12 years um and we would absolutely love
to add optional uh electronic filing for
for domestic violence survivors it is
expensive um and that is typically the
barrier every time we add a new case
type we have to contract with an ecourt
Filer and and there's a cost that is
usually in the hundreds of thousands
associated with transitioning that case
type over which is a carry-on cost um so
that is why it is a a gradual process
typically but um if if the legislature
wants to to focus on particular areas
and and move those to electronic filing
um we supportive we would love to have
those options um we do not typically
require a person who wants to do a paper
filing even in a an electronic case type
to demonstrate any kind of special need
there are a large number of
self-represented litigants in New
Hampshire and if they're not comfortable
or they don't have access to the
internet um we we allow them to come in
and give us a paper filing even in an
electronic case type so um that's even
though we try to make sure that more is
available electronically we we don't
want to exclude anyone who wants to file
by paper um for domes violence survivors
in particular the paper case type is a
very popular option even though in 2020
we at no cost created our own impromptu
email filing system with the working
with the Coalition and others 95% of
domestic violence survivors continue to
use the paper option um there could be
any number of reasons that this is true
it it could be that they just feel
physically safer coming into the
courthouse it could be their worried
someone's going to look at their
internet history uh but for whatever
reason this remains a very popular
option and we would have concerned if it
didn't remain an option um we would
certainly be happy to add the additional
option of going to a contractor and
specifically Building A system that has
a safe button that someone can press and
they can get away from that screen if
their abuser is in their presence we we'
want to design an electronic man uh
filing system that works for domestic
violence survivors and and we would we
would absolutely love to do that but we
don't want to take an option away that a
lot of a lot of survivors use um it's
still a very very high highly utilized
solution um so I I've I've I've told you
about our our gradual path toward
electronic filing we are working on it
and some of the unfortunate costs that
that can come with making those
transitions um a a very sort of minor
flag it's just drafting wise this has
been something and I know that the prime
sponsor was concerned about this and
it's a very good flag because I know
she's an attorney that this has
typically been a process which the
courts have done through the
administrative Authority that the the
courts have to make decisions which
administer the courts and it has not
typically been something that the
legislature has been involved in so
every time we've transitioned a case
type we' we've done it by an
administrative order because we've been
able to get the funds to do it um so
there's special drafting concerns but I
think those are completely overcomable
in terms of how the legislation is
phrased because we would absolutely love
to work with you to add this as an
option for
survivors would it be safe to say that
this would pass constitutional muster
with the separation ation if it were
more enabling versus mandatory for the
courts yes and if the legislation were
to pass as even as amended as suggested
taking out the shell does the court have
the funds because I see the fiscal note
there's there's no money um attached to
it the cost is about $300,000 to to add
this as a new uh electronic filing case
type so we would need to get new funds
for that but we would utilize them and
we would absolutely did you get did you
get the request for the fiscal note for
on the legislation we did and I I had
thought that it was noted there is it
not on oh maybe it is I just saw
zeros okay um representative
rhods thank you Mr chairman if could you
just clarify I wasn't sure if you said
if it was 90 or 95% of um the victims
that use the the paper filing option can
you representative sitec uh we heard
that there was a the court was doing a
pilot program in 2020 and all why do you
even need this legislation why can't you
just do it in order to uh build a a
platform a website that people can log
into that's going to have the features
that are going to be safe for survivors
to use like a safe screen button there's
just a certain cost associated with
building and maintaining that system
excuse me um but what we did in 2020
because we had to immediately deal with
the p pmic and we had to do something um
was we created basically a form that
people can email us and we receive it as
an email and we process it so that's not
what you get with e filing typically
what you get is an interface where you
can answer questions which is intended
to be much more userfriendly um there
are technical issues sometimes with our
totally self done um email system that
is is not at the level of functionality
that a a fully designed ecort filing
system would be it is utilized by about
5% of survivors so it's not that it's
not utilized and I think it was helpful
to have during the pandemic but you
would get something additional and it
might get a higher utilization if it was
a fully designed ecourt system followup
please followup what I heard is who's
going to
pay isn't that really what I heard
whether it's going to be through the our
budget process or the Court's budget it
it is it is a a large expense and I if
it were mandated without funds I am I am
not certain how we would resolve that
issue thank
you see no further questions thank you
for your testimony thank you is there
anyone else wishing to testify on this
pill who has not testified on the spill
seeing none I will close the public
hearing on House Bill
break
e
thank you um I'm here by opening the
executive session on House Bill
1177 and I recognize representative here
motion I motion to itl HB
1177 uh I'll second Mr chair thank you
representative here Gaff would you like
to speak to your motion yes sir um what
we have today from what I understand we
already have electronic fing if someone
chooses to go to um let's say a
designated lo location um verse being at
the state in into the normal um office
so with that said I I think we already
have two ways of folling electronically
in a safe location as well as going in
and um using paper so um I would say
if if the department chooses that they
want to look at um electronic filing
only in their location I believe that's
something that should be worked out
within that department not necessarily
come before us to make that decision for
a
department but Department you mean like
the Judiciary yes okay representative
rhs would you like to speak to your
second thank you Mr chairman um I I Echo
everything that uh representative herck
gri said I also just would like to
mention that the the
opposition that it seems like we're all
in agreement to is this is not a time to
be taking away any options from a person
that needs to have their voices heard
and whatever option that they have that
they feel is best for them is is what we
need to make available to them and
making it easier not more difficult by
any means so thank you Mr chair thank
you I I would add that
um the the sponsors seem to be open to
the idea of making it uh maybe instead
of a shell but if it becomes a maybe
there's already a maybe available so I'm
not really entirely sure of the goal of
the legislation if it's to to make a
more efficient system to track
statistics to know what what's going on
I think there's a a better way to do
that that if they work with the uh
Judiciary in advance um that we could
maybe come up with a more streamlined
bill that has a clear goal versus um
something that we're really not entirely
sure what it does if we change it
further
discussion see un asked the clerk to
call the
role motion on the floor is inexpedient
to legisl Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt yes yes
representative scitec yes representative
janen representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tzar yes
representative Harry gther yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balden yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative suig yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy chair votes yes
180 180 unanimous any objection consent
seeing none ofo on consent I hereby
close the executive session on House
Bill
1177 open the public hearing on House
Bill 1214 and recognize the sponsor to
bill
thank you Mr chair and thank you
criminal justice committee and um a
little nervous it's first time I'm
introducing my own bill so to introduce
myself I am representative Lauren selig
I represent the town of Durham New
Hampshire which is straford 10 um and
I'm one of our Representatives um House
Bill 1214 is a bill to create a study
committee to look at Best Practices for
the de um related to the development of
a restor restorative justice model for
misdemeanor behavior and hate crimes
committed by juveniles um under the age
of 18 and I know that that essentially
restates what a juvenile is but just to
be explicit um how this came about as an
idea for me is over the summer there was
um a surge in hate crimes around the Sea
Coast in particular a lot of it was
graffiti based but there were a number
of other somewhat more malicious crimes
that were occurring in the area um and
there are some indication that some of
it was more of it was was being caused
by young people than others um there's
also been you know surge in my
daughter's uh High School of people
putting hateful symbols in bathrooms and
and other places um at the same time as
that I was reading about the Howard
County Maryland's Teen Court program
where um they have a a program where
teens serve as the members of the Court
they're supervised by adults but their
teens who either themselves had brushes
with the judicial system or where they
have an interest in learning more about
the judicial system and they work
together with teens who have committed
an offense to identify um a way for them
to improve their behavior and make
restoration to whomever they've harmed
by their behavior and in recognizing
that putting more people in jail isn't
going to stop people from um having
feelings and emotions and isn't going to
necessarily help fix these things I
started thinking well what could we do
to really take teens in particular and
help them understand the severity of
their actions before they end up in a
long-term placement in a judicial system
and maybe end up needing the to be in
the judicial system for the rest of
their lives or in some way that impacts
the rest of their lives and so I spoke
with members of the ACLU I spoke with um
one of the attorneys at the Attorney
General's office um who works in their
hate crimes
Division and I spoke with people who
work in restorative justice with youth
models already um and there are some
models that exist but they're all
adult-led um and they don't necessarily
all end up being successful the Howard
County model um has had a 94% success
rate um their
recidivism um sorry that word's been
tripping me up has been very very low um
students have have the the young people
who have ended up involved in their
juvenile court system and their peer
court system have had very few instances
of re defending and
so I started thinking there are all
these different ways and we do have some
programs that are working in New
Hampshire but maybe need to be tweaked
and we also have programs that used to
exist and don't any longer so how could
we bring together our partners to really
take a look at what we have and make
things better so that we can a save
money because putting people in jail is
really expensive uh B break the cycle so
that kids are not just not committing
crimes but also encouraging their peers
not to commit them um and see you know
maybe if we have more kids who are
invested in being involved in the
judicial system as young people maybe
they'll learn much more and be
contributing members of society in other
ways and so that's where my my
motivation for all of this came
from thank
you would you your your bill seems to uh
create a new
commission would or are you aware that
you can task an existing commission with
legislation to to examine a new a new
issue so for example the inter Branch
commission that already has as its as
its role according to the information we
received from our researcher to look
into these Juvenile Justice System
issues you could say the interbranch um
commission is hereby tasked with abbc
and and study it um so I did not know
that but also I spoke to one of the
people who works with that organization
and uh with that commission and she was
very focused on the fact that they have
adult model programs that are working on
teen issues and I said I asked her about
the idea of having more of a teen
focused um more peer related and uh her
response seemed to be um less than
enthusiastic about um looking at it from
a different lens and so my thought was
well if we can bring in Partners to talk
about it maybe we can make the lens
wider to look for better
Solutions um I'm also on that commission
and I would I would welcome a new task
because I don't think we've met um so I
I think that regardless of someone's
interest in it or not if they're tasked
with looking at a certain issue and
discussing and bringing in a b and c
then they have to it's it's the law so I
just wanted to make you aware of that
okay versus creating a whole new
commission that will go on in
propertuity until whenever yeah this was
to be a a short-term study committee but
I would be more than open to uh
modifying it to to test them with that
as well or in instead any further
questions representa
Muse just a quick question and I'm not
sure if you can answer this or the chair
but is this the same inter Branch
commission that we've also potentially
tasked with trying to better understand
pre-trial diversion programs in the
context of bail
reform yes it
is okay sounds like a lot of work thank
you if they get to work we sent them
which is still tile somewhere else U
further
questions see none thank you and the
chair
recognizes um I'm sorry Mr CH I'm sorry
um I did receive testimony from the ACLU
in support um their representative was
here earlier but had a commitment at
this time and had to leave so she's
distributed paper copies to everyone
thank you we have it uh the chair AI is
representative
n thank you very much um for the record
my name is representative jod new and I
represent chesher 4 over uh in Kean and
I wanted to speak to this bill uh
particularly as the mother of uh two
teenage boys um just before my son was
going into high school um there was a a
a large concern um in an increase in all
kinds of behaviors um and some of them
were uh would fall under the behaviors
that would be addressed in this
situation um I've since learned um about
you know obious obviously the issue has
gotten better in the last 3 years um
I've since learned also about um a
community uh it is a restorative
Community model that has been used and I
feel like that is pretty similar to this
one unfortunately I didn't have the time
uh I did not um reach out to the person
who is leading that uh to bring them in
uh in time for them to come and speak to
this but hopefully we we can get some
testimony on that what I was thinking is
that um that would be a wonderful person
to be able to contribute to the
conversation if we were indeed to come
up with a uh form this study committee
um so I just wanted to speak to this as
a mom of kids who sometimes do um very
silly things and things that may be
interpreted um in very negative ways as
a manifestation of um you know what we
have also seen as a um Mental Health
crisis uh suicidal ideation is up
substance use is up and um I feel very
much that a lot of these um um
concerning behaviors are also part of
that that same issue and if we can uh
come up with a better model to deal with
that um and that actually addresses kind
of behavior modification rather than
criminalization or um punitive
approaches I think that that would be a
very good
thing thank you
questions see none thank
you the chair
jow
there we go hello members of the
committee my name is Lind Jake house and
I am a co-founder of 603 equality and I
strongly support this bill while I not
an expert on restorative justice I know
that restorative justice is more
productive in resolving Community issues
than punitive measures additionally
people must willingly participate in
restorative justice practices for to
work and the same restorative justice
practices must apply to everyone to hold
the entire Community accountable
restorative justice practices can
include uh things like facilitation
between offender and victim peer
mediation and conflict resolution
circles hosting dialogue circles and
student integration following suspension
for restorative justice to work students
must First Trust the process and if
successful it allows everyone within the
community to be held accountable to each
other but that can only happen if people
are not forced but participate willingly
in peer mediation Circle students who
may get into a fight for example talk it
out amongst each other in hopes of
intervening before the issue becomes an
even bigger problem in dialogue circles
students sit in larger circular shape
facing each other to check in with each
other settle disputes or perhaps even
hold old academic intervention
um after student has done offense
restorative justice can allow for
integration through hosting circles with
parents School administrators and the
student to find a be best path forward
it has also been proven to prevent
students from falling into the school to
prison Pipeline and teachers Al also
benefit from restorative justice as it
has been proven to improve the behavior
in the classroom dramatically I've also
had conversations with the assistant New
Hampshire Attorney General who has
stressed that they want to work to stem
hate crimes and incidents committed by
juveniles before they may grow into
something more harmful additionally I
would encourage members of this
committee through formal or informal
need means to work with the members of
the study committee on the following
questions what are the origins of
reported restorative justice and what
constitutes true reproductive Justice
and who is a qualified restorative
justice expert facilitator trainer or
consultant in speaking with a parent of
a high school student of color who is
also a member of the lgbtq community who
experienced racial bullying and
attempted to go through a restorative
justice process this parent stress that
they have often seen restorative justice
so-called experts who don't know the
origin of restorative justice Traditions
who don't understand um the
intersectional nature of this work and
who don't have the background on
systemic structures of Oppression um who
have traumatized students and
restorative justice circles due to their
own biases um basically some of these
these folks do not have the proper
skills and background and end up doing
more harm than good many of us are
learning and growing each day how to do
better but I would hate to see a
restorative justice program fail to
serve the people who need it most
because it is not structured in a way um
that um fails to um stem additional
harms um so I would encourage um folks
to move forward um with um ensuring that
uh the study committee a Works to have
restorative justice experts facilitators
trainers and Consultants who have lived
experience proper training and
certifications and a greater
understanding of why hate crimes are so
prevalent I would urge the study
committee to pay special attention to
you any
questions seeing none thank you for your
t
testimony anyone else wishing to testify
in this bill who has not testified in
this bill seeing none I hereby close the
public
hearing and I open the public hearing on
House Bill
1344 and intro invite the sponsor to
Bill thank you Mr chairman committee
members I am here to introduce House
Bill
1344 for the prime sponsor who is sick
and cannot present it
today
um I submit to you today House Bill 1344
relative to criminalizing the enticement
and manipulation of minors to engage in
sexual activity this bill will amend RSA
6393 and add language to RSA
632-a um semicolon one to bring the
enticement of children to include not
only online but inperson solicitation
and make it a crime as well I understand
that determining the attent is a
challenge but there has been extensive
studies to determine the outline of
universally accepted model for the five
stages of the process as published in a
book by George winter
2022 federal statute might appear to be
discussing sex trafficking yet case law
determined that that travel is not
required if the minor is induced enticed
or coerced into sexual activity this
might lead to um prosecution without
actual State
legislation in addition to the federal
statute there are 42 US states that have
developed an anti-solicitation
legislation but unfortunately many
including New Hampshire specify that the
enticement must involve the use of
electronic devices computer internet or
text messaging meaning the law may not
Encompass in-person sexual
manipulation this type of behavior has
been going on since the beginning of
time and it is never too late to step up
to protect children and make sure that
our legislation addresses this Behavior
fully and from every angle the these
laws must be used as a tool to prevent
child sexual abuse legislation
preventing pre- abuse behaviors such as
sexual enticement can stop the action
prior to the actual abuse going forth
sexual enticement both in person and
online regardless of whether it results
in a contact offense or the transmission
of sexual abuse material needs to be
made into a crime onto itself to achieve
this legislation needs to be clear and
consistent across jurisdictions and
based upon current research I offer this
legislation as an additional step in the
right direction for the welfare of our
children I offer chapters 16 and 17 of
Miss Winter's books as well for your use
thank
you thank you as a co-sponsor are you
pretty familiar with the drafting of
this and history or no actually I'm not
a co-sponsor I was asked to present it
okay um but I I are there anyone here
that's a co-sponsor this
bill okay thank you um all right I was
going to ask if anyone knew if anyone
consulted with the county attorney or
the Attorney General's office as to the
enforceability of it but I can look in I
can actually text um the prime sponsor
and and find that out for you okay all
right thank you thank you um since
you're not a sponsor and can't really
answer any questions I guess that' be it
thank you for
your okay you can try oh all right well
I just wanted to say that Manion pointed
out to me actually that um the well just
cuz he won't speak up for himself you
know
that's we're in this dark corner over
here I don't know so but um the judicial
branch judicial council department of
justice Department of Corrections and
the association of counties were
contacted when it and that's on the
fiscal note there yeah but that's with
regard to what it would cost them not
their opinion on to I don't think on to
whether or not it's a constitutional or
well they would be here I would hope
yeah um but that's not always the case
all right thank you um with that I'll
close the public hearing on House Bill
1344 was there anybody else wanted to
testify no oh was there anyone else
wishing to testify I don't have any
cards oh
um if you could when you're finished get
a card please so we know that you're
testifying we need to keep people's um
testifying uh good afternoon my name is
Eric Kinsman I'm a lieutenant with the
ports and police department and the
current Commander for the New Hampshire
internet crimes against children task
force over the last few years extortion
cases across the country including here
in New Hampshire have tripled over the
past year alone law enforcement agencies
in the United States have received over
7,000 reports related to online sex
tortion of minors these are cases where
a person through deception on social
media sites or in person uses a sexually
explicit photo or video sent to them by
another person to extort them out of
money or more photos or videos the
perpetrator threatens to reveal that
photo or video to people the victim yes
sir are you are you wishing to testify
on House Bill 1344 house bill 1500 or
I'm here for 1344
currently okay all right I'm sorry I
just saw the next one had um false and
misleading videos so I thought that was
a continue pardon but I I mean I I'll be
here for that one too yeah yeah so sorry
you're stuck with me
sorry uh no problem uh the perpetrator
threatens to reveal that photo or video
to people the victim cares about and if
they don't comply with their demands and
when left with that choice the victims
are faced with an extremely difficult
and embarrassing decision ultimately it
causes mental health mental welfare
concerns in some cases has led to victim
suicide expending the language in RSA
639 col 3 to what is proposed in House
Bill
1344 will allow iak investigators to
have a broader opportunity to charge
into individuals with sextortion related
crimes and thus have a direct impact on
keeping children of New Hampshire safe
thank
you thank you for your testimony um have
you had an opportunity to review this
legislation with one of the County
attorneys and um if so have they given
you any kind of an opinion on whether
they thought it was worded correctly uh
not directly no um you know my testimony
is coming just purely with how we
currently uh charge these crimes
whenever we have a sex dation related
crime we currently charge them under the
uh the 649 statute there certain uses of
Computer Services but as was stated
before sex ortion related crimes have
becoming basically unfortunately these
perpetrators have becoming very very
good at their tradecraft and they've
expanded their ability to to uh
perpetuate these crimes so if we had a
sexor related crime that sort of Falls
outside of it being done through a
computer then it sort of handcuffs us if
you excuse the pun with being able to
you know charge someone like this
expanding the language in a an
environment where these crimes are being
perpetrated in newly creative ways
expanding this language will give us a
better opportunity to charge individuals
in the future thank you and I I have
full understanding how difficult it is
to bring one of those cases which is why
I always want to make sure that the law
as written would enable the prosecution
actually take the work you've done and
apply it in the court so I'll follow up
with them thank you I appreciate any
questions for detective representative
um um s and then new thank you and thank
you for taking my question um in reading
the bill it it talks about Prosecuting
any person who engages someone under the
age of 16 with a you know with with
these acts um and I'm just trying to
make sure that I fully understand
because it's not my area of expertise if
if you had two 15-year-olds and engaging
in mutually Mutual consent would they
then both be subject to prosecution if
they're having mutually consensual touch
of the nature described in this yeah
because they'd be under the age of 15
they would be under the age of 16 so if
we had two you had two 15y olds you
could I can tell you that from
experience that we typically do not uh
you know we iak faced we had over 2,000
cases in 2022 alone or 2023 Alone um and
you know those were some pretty serious
cases whenever we have cases that
involve juveniles it it it there's a
whole another you know set of rules that
we have to play by
so thank you y representative Newman I'm
I'm going to pass I just going to ask
how would it improve the bill and I
think he's explained that thank
you represent scitech you have I can't
believe this you had 2,000 sextortion
cases in Portsmith in the year no no no
sir uh not 2,000 sextortion cas cases so
without kind of going off in a tangent
iak receives uh its cases uh through
what's called they're called cyber tips
from the national Center for missing
exploited children so we received over
2,000 cyber tips last year those cyber
tips include sextortion cases as well
there's a whole Litany of cases that
they included but sextortion cases are
lumped into that
number generally there um all cases that
involve abuse of children be it sexually
or otherwise any alleged child sexual
material crime that is occurring over
the internet thank you and what
jurisdiction does itch cover so the
entire State okay there are 61 iak task
forces across the country every state
has its own some states have more than
one just based on their size but uh New
Hampshire is is its own entity so those
cases that are coming uh with any IP
address resolving inside the the state
comes to New Hampshire
iak thank you um any further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
could you please pull out one of those
pin cards so we know how to get in touch
with you if we want to afterwards
absolutely appreciate it is there anyone
else wishing to testify on this bill
seeing none now I close public hearing
and I mean it this time um with that I
open the public hearing on House Bill
1500 and invite the sponsor to introduce
the
bill
you know who it
is oh she said she had to go yeah oh she
had those kids with her maybe she still
backs
we're going to be in um we're going to
be we're going to take a 10-minute break
hopefully the sponsor will come back I'm
assuming she intends to come back so um
we're just going to take 10 minutes and
we'll start up
a good to see you
again
yeah
reopening public hearing and I invite
the sponsor to introduce the
[Applause]
Bill thank you Mr chairman thank you
honorable members of the of the
committee um I apologize for you having
to take a recess but I had to go get the
amendment which I thought was over at OS
but actually was up on the fourth floor
so if I look thinner that's why okay um
1500 though House Bill 1500 is not
perfect it is a step into unfamiliar
territory that needs some definitions
and penalties in place regarding
synthetic
material uh sorry synthetic media its
misuse and effect on individuals and
their
privacy AI is a digital
Frontier Security Experts describe it as
a serious Potential Threat where State
lawmakers could play a vital role by
adopting Safeguard legislation that
could be used as models for federal
laws in
2023 nearly 200 AI related bills were
introduced in 31 state legislatures with
New York New Jersey Illinois and
California leading the way many related
to privacy
issues I believe the relevance of
hb500 became obviously apparent this
Monday when WMUR TV reported that the
New Hampshire Attorney General's office
had handled numerous calls complaining
about an artificially generated Robo
call of President Joe Biden's voice
telling voters their vote would not
count on primary day but will count in
November this was viewed as an unlawful
attempt by a political committee to
disrupt the election the AG's office is
now looking at it as a possible case of
voter
suppression Jeffrey hin who is the uh
British Canadian computer
scientist and he's also a cognitive
psychologist who's been deemed The
Godfather of AI he
worried about the potential of AI to do
harm so we can always amend
legislation but it's difficult for
people to ameliorate their lives when
they have no laws to reference no
defined recourse or penalties to utilize
to help them gain back their
lives so thank you for your
consideration thank you could you just
give us a brief um rundown in your
estimation what this bill will do okay
what it does is
if synthetic media is going to be
utilized whether it's in the political
Arina or you know just on the Internet
or whatever that it's has to be first of
all the person who is involved say it's
a disgruntled boyfriend with his ex and
he puts on the media something negative
either with her picture or her saying
something that he can't do that unless
he has her
consent that's just you know for for the
general public um another piece of it is
if you're going to be using AI you have
to note if it's a video or whatever that
it is AI is being used in this form and
so that the person who's viewing it
knows that AI has some factor in what
you are
viewing the other thing is um with the
election piece of it as we so vividly
found out on day it's happening right
here so the feds are looking to the
states to be the ones to move the bar
here and of course you know we're we
could always be behind the bar because
AI is so far ahead of us but at least
it's a step so that if somebody finds
thems a victim of AI um as far as media
whatever then they at least know there
with regard to personal individuals
would this Encompass um for for example
um we're hearing a lot about um people
taking someone's head and putting it on
a nude body and portraying that as that
person or any other number of false
portrayals of people where they been
manipulated by AI MH yes thank you
representative rhods thank you Mr
chairman could you explain how how this
would be a B to be enforced with with
Commerce if a person lives in a a
different state and there and you know
especially with social media because it
sounded like you you had mentioned that
a lot and I'm just curious how we would
enforce that so you're asking if it had
to do with somebody in another state as
the perpetrator or the
victim perpetrator I would be good to
start I I think I think this is more
designed for the
victim as far as they have a recourse of
what they can do um a person that has
the um ability to utilize another
person's image um they will it would be
called if they are convicted it would be
a Class A misdemeanor which would be up
to 12 months in jail or 2,000 up to
$2,000
fine thank you further
questions see represent
Murray thank you Mr chair um thank you
for taking my question um do you have
any concerns about potential Free Speech
violations considering there's no
exception for irony or sarcasm in this
bill and also potentially an overly
broad definition um with this amendment
um on computer editing of photographs
almost anything that's going to be put
online would be edited on a
computer um as far as the concern goes I
think that the Free Speech has more to
do with
um are you talking about specifically
Free Speech or are you talking about the
image um both but if you want to uh
address the Free Speech concern first
well again if the I AI was being used it
would have to be noted somewhere visibly
or AUD audibly um so therefore that part
of it would be notified first for the
um I guess you know even if it's noted
it said it would still need to be done
with the consent of the person right
okay um and then with the um editing
images part with the definition as you
expanded it in the amendment um
um I have someone who will be speaking
to the amendment so um you can ask them
okay repres Manion thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
I know people who make memes especially
political ones they post on Twitter and
whatnot um if I were to reshare that
without knowing that they don't have
consent of the person would I now be in
violation of this
law you know that's a good question and
and um I think it would have to do with
intent I intentionally share re
retweeted it or res shared it not
knowing but I
intentionally I think the question of
intent is was your intent to share an
edited False
Image knowing that it wasn't right
legally obtained or created perhaps
right but I would know that and I guess
my question if I can clarify it is a lot
of these memes are clearly of a
different body with a political
candidate's face on it with something
funny said on top and bottom I clearly
know it's not that person's body it's a
cartoon or whatever and I reshare that
online would I now be in violation of
this
law if would to pass um again I I I
don't know it would have to do an intent
I believe thank
Muse your your bill is uh is is very
broad um and it it doesn't appear to
identify uh distribution so one of the
questions that I have is would uh a
party involved in the wider distribution
of this media um also be guilty of of a
crime so for example if WMUR winds up
running an advertisement um that uses uh
synthetic media improperly but that
information isn't disclosed to WM R
would
W um also be subject to a
penalty that that's a very good question
and to be honest with you I hadn't
factored that in so that may be
something that needs to be worked on
okay thank you thank
you representative
Stone thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question under Section Five
item two can you give me an example of
what you envision that would be an
example of that that would be
enforced section five item two section
yeah a person is convicted of an
election related misleading synthetic
media based on a complaint that alleges
that the actor distributed the election
related misleading synthetic media with
a further purpose to provoke
violence um I I'll be very honest with
you I have someone here can speak to
that better I'd be willing to hear okay
good thank you
see no further questions thank you for
the introdution you and with that I
Corman thank you chairman Roy I'm
representative Tom Corman from Grafton
15 which is Ward three of the city of
Lebanon I have been in computer science
for for literally 50 years I started in
1974 I have computer science degrees
from Princeton and MIT I was a professor
of computer science at Dartmouth for 29
and a half years my research is not in
artificial intelligence it never was but
as a practicing computer scientist and
somebody who had to keep track of the
broad field I certainly kept track of
what was going on in artificial
intelligence for at least the last 40
years I've seen the amazing progress
that AI has made 40 years ago AI seemed
dead in the water people were making fun
of neural Nets and then a few years ago
things changed neural Nets became quite
capable as people realized how to
construct them and we're seeing the
results now in
AI I always hesitate to use the term
exponential because I'm a quantitative
person and I know exponential means but
it seems like we are having literally
exponential growth in
AI what we have now is a situation where
it's so easy to create deep fakes it
would not be hard to create a video of
chairman Roy talking about how much he
admires Bernie
Sanders that that video actually exists
okay
well
so I'm very concerned about what misuse
of AI can happen um and it's only going
to get worse right I mean we think of
what we have now it's continuing and
it's only going to get worse the the the
the potential for abuse it's just going
to
increase this bill uh I think actually
has some of the guard rails that some of
the committee members were just asking
about so for example somebody just asked
about what if um somebody uh produced a
deep fake video a malicious deep fake
video and WMUR ran it well if you look
at line 13 of page one of the bill uh
with the intent of misleading others
about the acts of the identifiable
person presumably WMUR is not intending
to be misleading they or or trying to
defame anyone they're just running the
video so I I I think that the broadly
this bill is is in the right place there
might be some changes you might want to
make to it to uh narrow the scope of the
bill but I do believe it's really in the
right place here trying
to guard against a lot of the abuse that
we're going to see and of course as as
the sponsor pointed out and as you all
know it hit New Hampshire two days ago
and with that I'm happy to take
questions
representative
sake thank you Mr chair I'm sorry I I
just am trying to wrap my head around
all the different components of this
bill so I have a a kiddo who takes
photos at sporting events at school and
then uses various software editing
programs to improve those photos before
very deliberately Distributing them both
to members of the team and to social
media on behalf of the various teams and
it feels like that would be at risk
within this statute given the broadness
of the language right of because she's
deliberately using software programming
that has an artificial ability to M edit
the photos um and so I just I'm trying
to understand how that plays out into
this maybe you could help help me
understand myself better sure thank you
representative Cel uh well one thing is
that the bill specifically says through
the use of artificial intelligence
algorithms and many of the algorithms
that you would see in video or or uh
especially just uh image editing
software are NE not necessarily uh would
would be classified as AI algorithms um
so so there's that and then um just in
terms of misleading others about the
acts of the identifiable person uh you
know if it I think there it depends on
on on what your what your child intends
to do right so if your child's trying to
show one of their teammates chopping off
the head of somebody on the other team
yeah that would probably be a bad thing
to do but if they're just trying to show
that the the person was doing something
you know good then I don't think that
problem further questions representative
Muse I I know you're a computer science
expert and not a First Amendment expert
um um but one of the things I'd like to
ask you about is do you think that there
are um appropriate uses of of this
technology and specifically when it
comes to the ability to
um change somebody's facial appearance
so they appear to be somebody else and
I'm thinking specifically of things uh
like
parody I'm sorry like what like parody
oh parody
yeah
um you I I I think if there's one thing
missing from this bill it's it's
specifically stated intent that that
that there should be something malicious
or or
defamatory behind it um I actually have
a bill uh in Edna that would limit what
state agencies can do with AI and there
it it specifically says malicious or or
defamatory so that might be something
that that the committee might wish to
amend the bill to
include um I can certainly
imagine good uses of deep fakes and you
know when I was thinking about the bill
that I did submit I was thinking you
know an obvious deep fake would be You
Know Abe Lincoln talking about forest
fires right it it would be possible to
do that and I don't think anybody would
say oh this is just a horrible thing to
do Abe Lincoln would never talk about
forest fires and also there was never
video taken of Abe Lincoln yeah I think
that further questions representative
Newman yeah I I just have a quick
question about line 11 that says without
displaying a cons they'd be guilty
without displaying a conspicuous notice
within the synthetic media identifying
it as synthetic media so if if I was
creating this media and without the
consent of the individual that was
involved but on all my media I put a
little comment down this says synthetic
media would I then be okay with this
it so my answer to that is that as long
as the synthetic media really is clearly
labeled as such if you know if a video
says this was produced by AI or
something similar to that if an image
said that if the rooc calls that came in
two days ago
actually said this this is a uh
reconstruction of of President
Biden as long as the person who is
viewing or hearing or experiencing the
media understands that it was produced
by AI
then if they're deceived it's on
them thank you thank you I would just
remind the committee as Witnesses come
up we do have uh one of the County
attorneys who's going to testify at the
end uh try and save your legal questions
Balden thanks for taking my question as
I'm looking at the bill language um and
listening to the testimony I'm reminded
of a couple things um I remember when um
when we have in the past tried to deal
with robocalling from a technical
perspective from a legal
perspective um and the particularly the
issue of like spoofing a phone number
that some of the drawbacks to Banning
spoofing phone numbers was that if there
was a cause for spoofing a number like a
reasonable purpose like um calling out
from maybe you're working from home
you're a nurse you need to call a
patient to reschedule something but it's
covid or it's snowed so you're working
from home you want to be able to spoof
the number to call from the office so
that you're not giving out your personal
number um and I'm also reminded of like
um those commercial on the radio for car
dealerships where it's definitely like
people mocking the voices of notable
people
presidents um so my question is in those
situations um thinking about how there
may be useful reasons to mislead people
and how there may be beneficial ways for
businesses to mislead people and
considering that we already require a
paid for by disclaimer and we can
already prosecute people who mislead the
public about election law um considering
how they're investigating this how does
this legislation as it's worded play
into all of those situations are we
going to limit not that I would mind
never hearing one of those car
commercials again but how would it
affect that in your opinion thank you in
terms of spoofing phone numbers I don't
see that as gerine to this particular
bill um I see that is
as not really about synthetic media um
so I I wouldn't view that I think is
using that as an example of how
technology can be used yeah yeah but
just in terms of of that specific
question I I don't think it's Germaine
to this particular
Bill uh yeah so I I don't know which car
commercials I haven't heard any car
commercials with um SPO of famous voices
or anything like that um I think I think
what I would say there is
that yeah they probably should be saying
that it's not the actual person just to
be very clear about it unless it's just
I think really really obvious that it
couldn't be the actual person for
example if they had uh if there was a
car commercial with somebody doing an
imitation of John F Kennedy our
president the former president that John
F Kennedy um advertising for Chevy
Tahoe I think we all know that that's
not really JFK advertising for a Chevy
Tahoe but I I I would say you know in my
opinion and it's just my opinion if
there's any doubt as to whether this is
clear see no further questions thank you
for your
testimony here calls representative
Jonah
wheeler thank you you Mr chairman
members of the committee it's a little
scary being on this side of the Das I'd
have to say it's a little bit different
but um I just have to affirm my support
for representative milla's Bill I'm very
concerned with the rise of artificial
intelligence in our world today I think
as you know we've gotten to talk about
when it comes to should we allow kids
and and civil not kids but civilians to
be able to own these these weapons and
the military drone capabilities that uh
artificial intelligent
uh operating systems open up for our
world but I think another big concern
with artificial intelligence is the uh
ability that it has to mislead the
public and and misrepresentations of
famous politicians famous uh people
different events I mean um the
possibilities are kind of endless with
artificial intelligence and and what it
can be used for in this way and and I
think that's a concerning thing so I I
think as representative Mamilla said you
can't necessarily
uh and it was brought up in the last AI
hearing that we had to in regards to
weapons addressing this is going to be a
hard thing for the legislature to do
when the technology is growing at such
an uh fast rate the acceleration of the
the rate of uh production and and how
how much research goes into it and and
the capabilities of the technology
doubles like every four months or
something like that um It's A Hard rate
to keep up with but I think instead of
not addressing it at all um it's more
incumbent on us to treat AI as the hair
and us as the tortoise where you know
yes the hair might be you know
significantly farther ahead of us but we
need to still be walking and dealing
with these issues as much as we can um
because of the serious effects that they
that they can have I mean the rooc call
thankfully didn't result in in all these
people not voting for The riding
campaign although as someone who didn't
support the writing campaign maybe that
wouldn't have been such a bad thing but
I think it is concerning if we ever have
a an event in which
um if we're talking about the
presidential campaign next year someone
can blast out onto social media some
video of President Biden or or president
Trump saying something completely
ridiculous but not so ridiculous that
it's unbelievable and then a sector of
the population of the electorate that's
just scrolling through on Facebook sees
this video it's 30 seconds long and it's
telling them don't vote the election's
actually on Wednesday we changed it to
Wednesday there's going to be a
significant chunk of people
unfortunately that make the decision to
vote on Wednesday and and we we did see
this in 2016 there were people who were
texted and said hey you can vote via
text and those people voted via text
voted via text and and their vote didn't
count um so and that's not artificial
intelligence that's just how people use
media and different narratives to
mislead the public so giving people this
tool now artificial intelligence the the
powers that be have this tool now and
it's going to be used in in some very
significant ways and the electoral
process and in business and all these
other things and I think th um there are
valid concerns for Free Speech but I
think there also should be a concern for
the basic fundamental foundation of the
truth where we can't have an election we
can't have a free and fair election we
can't have a free and fair process or
deliberative process process if there's
not some baseline of truth that we can
be able to operate from and I think the
danger with AI is it threatens the very
sanctity of that Foundation of Truth
which is already very fragile right now
I think in this moment in this country
and the more that there are these
synthetic audio video uh platforms out
there that people can create things that
totally mislead the population and I
think that the more we risk uh losing
that basic Foundation of Truth to be
able to then have uh these conversations
so I'm a I'm a respector of free speech
I want to I want to protect the First
Amendment um but I also want to make
sure that we can have those discussions
so the First Amendment means something
and then the final thing I'd say is to
representative balens point to answer
your question I have seen those
presidential commercials I know you know
the president State commercial where
they try to get Lincoln to sell you a
Chevy or something like that you I've
seen that um but I would agree with
representative Corman that I don't think
that really Falls under artificial
intelligence or uh any of the other uh I
I don't think it's necessarily Germaine
to what we're discussing here because um
we're talking about artificial
intelligence and and that very
specifically even when representative
Muse brought up um in his testimony
related to his bill uh the the example
of someone being able to use the face
app that you were using when you were in
business um you know those are those are
uh that's not necessarily what we're
discussing here we're talking about sort
of art legitimately artificial
intelligent algorithms that will be able
to to manipulate voice audio in in
significant enough ways to mislead the
public so I'll end with that I believe
that we should support this legislation
and make sure we can address the
technology as must we can even if it
means that we're the tortoise to the
hair thank you representative um and I
don't think that esops fables are
brought up enough in this committee so
thank you for exactly appreciate it um I
maybe the only one who who read it this
way but I think representative Balden
was trying to just show that as an
example of Technologies we've had to
deal with going along not that she's
concerned about presidential um
commercials but to the point this bill
would um address people using AI to
create
voices which it can currently do um so
that it is somewhat germine in that if
you created a commercial with someone
voice endorsing a product do you think
that that would be covered under this if
it was created using an artificial
intelligent platform and I think that
would be valid I I think if if you
created uh an advertisement you know
even if it was with someone who has
since passed I think it would be valid
to say this is an advertisement that's
used doing artificial intelligent with
some whatever the wording would be on
that because I think the example that
representative Balden uses um it's uh
pretty obvious that they're not it's
it's it's a it's an impersonator it's
it's someone going I'm Abraham Lincoln
and schz one is very good actually
exactly right and so uh the algorithms
the danger with them are they're so
perfect and it's not distinguishable
from reality but the the parodies the
the the misleading nature of doing an
advertisement for a business those are
definitely uh observable especially to
the to the regular lay person but but to
the lay person unfortunately uh the AI
algorithms are not so that would be my
answer to that thank you any further
questions to the representative keep in
mind that we will be discussing this in
you
Gallagher
hi I'm Eric Gallagher uh representing
Mar County District 20 which is
conquered w six I'm the co-sponsor of
this bill um testifying in favor of it
and also with an amendment that I'm
handing around um just some additional
language that I had proposed that got
lost in the shuffle of the drafting
process um so basically one of my or
some of my top issues are um software
freedom and open source advocacy um so
my uh amendment is basically intended to
introduce some elements of that into the
bill um I think it actually addresses um
a lot of the concerns that people were
asking about
previously um so it basically
um adds a criteria about disclosure of
the source code and training data to the
definition of synthetic media um so um
in the case of the question about um oh
how do we tell the difference between an
AI algorithm versus like just one of
your um
previous pre- AI hype type algorithms
that um get used in say Photoshop or
whatever which had actually been
considered AI too as well in previous
waves of AI but um don't think I don't
think they're what as part of the intent
here but anyways the way you tell the
difference there um would be is if
there's a question about it um it if
there's a court hearing then you would
take a look at the source code um have
an expert look at testify as to
whether the
um whether the algorithms
involved uh count as artificial
intelligence ones and then make your
decisions from that um and then um also
having to do with intent um I one of the
previous Witnesses was saying I think
there could be um an that there could be
an intent portion added um I think
looking at the source code of software
is a good way to figure out um what
exactly the programmer's intent was when
creating it um so I think that would be
an um additional helpful tool for
figuring out uh what might qualify under
this legislation or not um and um I'll
take a few questions but I have to be
out of here in a few minutes so let's
keep it
quick we'll keep that in mind any
questions
no questions that's how quick we are
Kinsman see I told you you couldn't get
me good afternoon I know I know I was
just here earlier for a previous bill
but uh for the record for the purposes
of this proposal uh my name is Eric
hinsman I'm a lieutenant with the ports
of police department and the current
commander of the New Hampshire internet
crimes against children task force um so
first of all just for the record um I uh
representative of mamea had reached out
to me uh with some uh looking for some
input uh because there was seemingly
there were some overlap with regard to
some of the statutes that we use when
we're talking about the dissemination of
non-consensual sexual images for example
or the distribution of child sexual
abuse material um so I thought it was
important for me to say for the record
that um you know while I do uh admit
that there seemingly is some editing and
some adjusting that needs to be done
with this proposal that in its Theory I
do uh support it um and that I am here
to speak in favor of uh House Bill 15500
uh and again just to clarify any
potential confusion that may arise as it
relates to I CAC related investigations
uh I can tell you that um while in some
regards we don't necessarily have a
position on this bill I can tell you
that it will not impact our ability to
prosecute iak related crimes because we
simply use other statutes when it talks
when we're talking about the
dissemination or the potential in
dissemination of synthetic Media or
artificial intelligence uh media we
would use we actually have uh another
bill um that we had proposed and written
so it would allow us to be able to cover
AI generated material U but I will say
that based on the intelligent uh
questions that were uh brought by the
committee earlier with previous
testimony um that I agree with you that
there does seem to be some work done
with this and that uh you know I'll
certainly offer my two cents but I just
thought it was important to make a note
that it it won't affect iak related
investigations at
all thank you
questions seeing none thank you for your
Spalding
good afternoon members of the committee
my name is Scott spradling I am a
representative of the New Hampshire
Association of broadcasters here in New
Hampshire which includes as our Client
List wmtv the radio stations New
Hampshire Public Radio um we are a
nonprofit Association who are
essentially working along with
broadcasters to help add voice to
conversations like this very important
one um like law enforcement allies like
all of you who are watching this issue
and seeing things like the headline
from uh what happened with the the this
call from allegedly Joe Biden and the
potential around artificial intelligence
in the broadcast Community there are
increasing concerns and in some cases
grave concerns about um having to filter
and police this system it's increasingly
difficult and um where we are with this
particular proposal is is simply this we
are very glad to hear that this
conversation is going on here at the
state level and it's also happening at
the federal level and I can share a
couple of thoughts about that um where
we have concern is in the language and
elements of the bill where it seems to
focus more on the Distributors and
distribution than it does on the
creators I think if there is any general
guidance that broadcasters would want to
share with you as you have this
important conversation and we certainly
encourage you to have it it's that
Precision matters you know we can joke
about and talk about what's the
definition of Art and you kind of you
know it when you see it um that's not
this the speed of AI is moving so much
quicker than even the broadcaster's
ability to try and keep up with it as
you all know the technology is becoming
so sophisticated it's really difficult
from time to time to know the difference
so representative MW asking the question
about if mu unwittingly put something
out there that in fact was um uh an AI
deep fake and um and this law this bill
was law um by our reading of it we would
be liable for that and this is
increasingly difficult and let me give
you one just super brief example uh
broadcast newsrooms are spending an
increasing amount of time and resources
to vet stories and footage verifying
sources to ensure they continue to
deliver trusted information for example
after the terrorist attacks on Israel in
October of
2023 fake photos and videos reached an
unprecedented level on social media in a
matter of minutes of the thousands and
thousands of videos that one broadcast
network sifted through to report on the
attacks they were only able to verify
roughly 10% now that's a broadcast
network using a great deal of resources
literally in the fog of a war to try to
figure out what's real and what's not so
to your point uh the odds are not in the
favor of people in the public to try to
keep up with and discern
really sophisticated AI but our message
is that very simply precision and
definition matters so in this
conversation the idea of a conspicuous
identification of what is AI it's going
to need to be more than something that's
conspicuous the AI algorithm may make
sense to a lot of people who are experts
in the field but to Everyday users of
media they may not know the difference
there is a lot of education and
definition that would have to go along
with a conversation like this the idea
of intent one person's intent versus
another could be very difficult to
discern and when you're putting
punishments in for wrongdoing intent
matters and again from the broadcasting
perspective if we are unable to tell the
difference and it takes time afterwards
when the horses left the proverbial Barn
um we have real we have real concerns
about being liable for things that which
we didn't know until potentially after
the fact and of course again just to re
reinforce the idea that this bill seems
to be focusing on distri ution and not
necessarily really focusing on
identifying and possibly penalizing the
creators of this content I think that's
where the focus needs to be so from the
broadcaster's perspective we um we uh we
appreciate you having this conversation
it's really important and it's important
at the federal level too because I think
we need a Level Playing Field Nationwide
especially since this is the kind of
material that doesn't respect state
lines and state borders we're going to
be dealing with a lot of outof State
entities which makes this even more
complicated So to that extent we just
have concerns about how this is set up
and we we would appreciate um your
understanding when it comes to
definitions around distribution thank
you questions represent
Muse recognizing that the bill uh isn't
perfect as the sponsor uh admitted in
the first line of Our
Testimony um one thing I am curious
about is what responsibility you think
uh broadcasters have when it comes to
disclosing material that's potentially
AI generated especially things like
election ads where the Integrity of our
election process and our our primary
process in particular is so important to
so many people you bet so there are
rules at the moment that don't yet
account for artificial intelligence
related technology that are the rules to
be followed I I think you use some
examples of you know historic figures
like Abraham Lincoln who have obviously
passed and you can spoof and everyone
sort of knows that that's not the real
deal we're now drifting very quickly
into a place where the leading
candidates for president the incumbent
and the lead Challenger could very
easily be uh taken advantage of through
AI technology to create speeches Andor
images that were never knew and are
incredibly difficult to discern
representative Muse to answer your
question directly it's really hard to
answer it because we don't necessarily
have equal access throughout broadcast
media especially at the local level to
the kind of Technology that's necessary
to Fed out what's real and what isn't
the example that I gave before was a
national Network that has more intense
resources to be able to discern that
kind of thing versus a local Newsroom
that might see things on social media
and if they can't verify it then their
rule is they can't use it so it's a it's
a it's an area of gray that I think
should also be discussed as part of this
bill around who has the responsibility I
can tell tell you that broadcasters take
this task very seriously and especially
from a local level you know my friends
at WM TV sift through the social media
that we all sift through to sometimes
see audio and video of events and things
that could be of a newsworthy and
noteworthy um level that they would then
share on TV they do their best to reach
out to the um the person that put that
out there to verify so there are steps
that are taken um but the technology is
now advancing past an easy ability to
discern whether or not it's even real
much less who put it out there so it's
it's a challenging conversation because
I think most of us want the free
exchange of information and what we want
to do is hold the Bad actors responsible
those who want to use this technology to
influence opinions and actions uh to
their control and that's where that
Focus needs to be so I think there are
steps that are taken we can be a part of
that conversation but it's it's a little
bit gray because there's no hard and
fast rule of
law
so about a year or so ago there was an
ad that ran on WMUR and it showed uh Joe
Biden walking around in some sort of
post apoplectic uh you know landscape
obviously it wasn't Joe Biden it was
obviously uh generated uh by by AI uh it
gave a misleading impression um and I'm
I'm
curious would we or would you you know
how would how would you suggest
broadcasters approach and AD they
receive like that today obviously this
was all very new uh a year or so ago but
knowing what you know now and having had
some of these conversations around
standards and what you should and
shouldn't run what are the processes
that you think stations like WM should
have in place when it comes to a
decision about whether or not to allow
an ad like that to to be run sure and I
think where where that comes down is um
there are federal laws that stations and
broadcasters have to follow and so the
example that you're using is along the
lines of something that is um pretty
easily identified by broad audiences as
a spoof that the ad in question that
you're talking about if if it looks like
he's stumbling around in some alternate
reality and it's very clear that that's
not like real video captured by of Joe
Biden doing something like that it it
sort of passes a basic common
understanding type of test that is
essentially what the barometer is around
broadcasting nowadays and I think the
challenge that we all face is that this
technology that we are talking about
poses a very real threat to what could
be a very obvious line between spoofing
and um something that's clearly not real
to using technology that makes it very
much look like Joe Biden was on the
phone with Vladimir Putin saying this
exact same quote holy cow this is
terrible so that is the kind of
challenge that I think we're all facing
and so for broadcasters obviously they
want to maximize the flexibility and
freedoms to be able to use the different
broadcast medium and content that's out
there but we definitely need to figure
out how to best identify and timestamp
and permanently Stamp Those things that
are created by AI so that we have a
fighting chance and I think that's where
the focus needs to be is around the
creation of this content and not
specifically around the distribution
helps
repres thank you and thank you for
taking my question um so is your
assertion because it it does seem like
in this bill there are some guard rails
because it's around intent right and
that might be a little fuzzy to um flesh
out but is your assertion that um that
is not um that's not sufficient to
protecting uh broadcasters against
liability for unknowingly yes
okay yes ma'am yeah I that is from from
a legal liability perspective I think
that's nowhere near sufficient and I
think that the the focus of this
conversation and this bill really should
start with those who are creating this
content in the first place and one of
the challenges this committee faces that
I think we all face is that we're all
connected globally and that the content
that could be creating problems for all
of us in this room may very well be
coming from places where we can't even
reach to them it just creates
complications and to point it's not like
so don't have the conversation we
support this and we want to be a part of
the conversation but yes we we do worry
about the the way this bill is written
it puts the broadcasters squarely in the
crosshairs of liability thank
you representative
scitec hi early in your remarks you said
that the federal government might be
doing something about this and you did
not elaborate on that are should we
maybe wait to see what the feds do
because they may just sweep all this
aside so they could I would never advise
uh the great people of the State of New
Hampshire to wait for Washington for
much of anything so with that said um I
what what I would hope is that we could
raise some awareness to conversations
that are ongoing I do believe that there
are there have been numerous US Senate
hearings in their Communications
committees as well as a absolutely
ongoing conversation around trying to
figure out policy through the Federal
Communications Commission the FCC that
oversees all broadcasting of radio and
television to try to figure out how to
begin tackling this there are hearings
going on but that I'm aware of there has
not been anything that has been
developed that would focus on the kind
today see no further questions thank you
Enders
good afternoon my name is Stephen ERS
I'm an assistant County attorney in
Marat County with me is attorney
Halverson who's the Marat County
attorney um both of us have been
prosecutors for over 20
years I don't necessarily support or
oppose this bill I just think there's a
couple things that are worth pointing
out or
discussing the the definition section
when it talks about synthetic media is
specific about media that is created or
modified through the use of artificial
intelligence
algorithms that I think would be a very
difficult thing to prove in court um
when we're talking about we had a bill
last week House Bill 1319 that talked
about synthetic images that had a much
broader definition which would include
things that were done without the use of
artificial intelligence when we're
talking about the the robo call the
recent Robo call of President Biden it
it strikes me that there's three
possible ways that something like that
is created the first one obviously is
artificial intelligence the the second
way that call could be created is if you
have someone who's really really good at
doing impressions of uh Joe Biden who
sits down and records that call and the
third way you could do it is there's
enough video of Joe Biden saying
probably almost every word in the Engish
English language at this point that if
you sat down and took a lot of time and
cut and paste and stitched all that
together you could probably come up with
a pretty
convincing um Joe Biden phone
call it would be difficult as a
prosecutor to prove sort of which one of
those three methods resulted in that
phone call being created I I understand
if we had the the source code of that
that call that we might be able to do
that but presumably as a process
prosecutor I'm not going to end up
having the source code of that call I'm
going to have a recording of it and that
recording isn't going to tell me
anything about how it was created um
which under this current definition I
would have to prove Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt in court that artificial
intelligence algorithms were used and I
think that becomes a difficult hurdle to
overcome the other thing that I would
suggest is paragraph two and then
paragraph three paragraph 3 talks about
um
elections we already have where this
638-2636
66 which is a very omnis statute but is
Provisions for Pur of
Elections uh I would suggest that for
two reasons the first reason is since it
is specifically an election Law related
statute I think it belongs better in the
election law section than in the
criminal law section the other reason
that I would suggest making it clear
that it goes into RSA 666 is that in New
Hampshire the Attorney General's office
has exclusive jurisdiction over all
election um and election interference
election fraud that type of thing so
normally as a county attorney's office
we would never see election interference
cases those would all go directly to the
Attorney General's office to be
prosecuted by them don't if you have
anything to
add the only the only comment I would
add would be um I'll start at the end of
attorney ers' comments if you do move
that section to the uh election law
obviously the penalty section would be
bifurcated split between the two uh the
two relevant statutes um the other one
comment that I have is on talking about
the a conspicuous notice within the
media um I think that we all know from
doing elections that we're required to
put a paid buy statement on our or on
our paid advertising stuff like that in
the printed media it's often a little
disclaimer down the bottom that someone
has to look for uh I think that as this
is written I think that a person doing a
complying with the with the note could
do that on an image or a video and it
not be obvious so I think you'd have to
Define what conspicuous is such as with
an image centered in the image so people
know it's conspicuous um uh so big such
a location contrasting uh text item such
as that I think that would have to be
fleshed
out
and
other than that I don't have any
additional any additional comments
gladly take your
questions thank you questions represent
Manion thank you Mr chair and thank you
for T taking my question uh this
question I'm gonna have a little
scenario with it but it's going to piggy
back on what Mr spradling said in the
question by rep new section three
specifically is so broad that if I were
to distribute a video I found on Twitter
or X of a p political candidate saying
something created by AI but I don't know
it but I distribute that because I know
that um it could be damning to that
candidate so I sent it to my friends
hoping to influence their
vote all I've I've reached every element
in that section there but I didn't know
I did it because I didn't know it was
fake so I could be charged is it your
opinion I could be charged under that
section
i' say yes yeah I mean my intent is I
would my intent is to specifically uh
right you know I would say technically
yes but I think that
the that the facts might dictate
discretion in the prosecution from my
office uh however Attorney General's
office since it's an election issue
would be the final Arbiter on the
election side of things in my opinion
but I've already been arrested and
charged and I've got to wait at that
point
AG's office I don't know how they would
view it thank you does the does the
statute in your opinion have um intent
and knowing as well I mean the proper
men's ready to actually to know what
you're being charged with and actually
doing it it could certainly be worded
more clearly that you purposely
distribute or make publicly available
within this state what the actor knows
is synthetic media um and that's not in
Balden um on the topic of I think
earlier another lawmaker brought
up teens on social media um if there
was I know like on not that I use it a
lot but on Instagram or Tik Tok or
something they have those fake faces you
can wear MH and it I suppose it's
possible for that fake face to be
modeled off of a real human being in if
maybe a teenager who doesn't understand
politics or something puts on a a trump
face and says vote for Joe Biden on
social media could that under this
wording could that minor be charged and
also would that would the minor be
responsible for making making it clear
that that's synthetic Media or would it
be the responsibility of the app or if
there's um like a thirdparty person
who's created the graphic would it be
their
responsibility yeah I think it would be
on the responsibility of the person
who's Distributing or making publicly
available that that document and I I
mean I can give you an example from my
past is there used to be a magazine
called Super Lawyers and it us it always
had you know the typical like lawyer
picture on the front
page and our office hired a new attorney
and I went on the bar website and I took
their photograph and I cut it out and I
pasted it on the cover of Super Lawyers
and I printed it out and I taped it to
her desk so that on her first day she
got this nice you know she's a super
lawyer I think technically if I did that
using artificial intelligence
algorithms that could potentially
run a foul of paragraph two unless I put
something on there
saying um you know this is synthetic
media I've I've made this up so I think
there is the potential for this statute
to be maybe broader than it intends to
be I think too that if it's if it's not
created by synthetic media and it's
obvious by the presentation someone
dressed up as somebody where obvious
differences between a real person and
the and a person dressed up as somebody
that may not fall on probably wouldn't
fall under this because it's not
synthetic
medor thank you Representative no thank
you um I just wanted to ask a question
it was brought up earlier in the
conversation around free speech and the
possibility that this would be free
speech and maybe this is more so
speaking about the Creator but I think
it could also be um it could also
pertain to someone who is sharing it is
um and let me just preface what I
understand you know the the concept of
of speech and and what defines that in
elections is pretty interesting
especially campaign Finance but my
question is where is the line um as far
as you know what what what is considered
Free Speech when you would essentially
be hijacking someone else's free speech
um to it's specifically about AI I'm
sorry I'm not explaining this well
specifically about AI in imperson
someone else I I wonder how that could
be considered someone's Free Speech when
it is intentionally hijacking someone
else's free speech I making sense I
think parody does that all the
time you know and certainly the
application needs to be content
neutral beyond that I think it's very
fact very fact
specific thank you I mean I I think
there's certainly Free Speech
implications with this
bill having said that that's a
constitutional law question not a
criminal law question um
hopefully um further questions seeing
none thank you both for your testimony
today anyone else wishing to testify in
this bill who has not done so seeing
none I hereby close the public
day